[Music]
foreign
nothing is faster and more exhilarating
in chess than a bullet game it's all
about quick thinking and taking
advantage of every opportunity when it
comes blink and you'll miss it how did
he do that
despite his popularity bullet chess only
has one annual championship tournament
and now entering its fifth year the
bullet Chess Championship is stronger
than ever three-time Champion Hikaru
Nakamura again looks to defend his title
and add to his impressive trophy case a
brutal finish
actually has won the only player who has
ever stopped Nakamura in this event also
returns to take another shot at it 2021
Champion alireza farugia that's it
competing with these champions for the
first time in the format the best
all-around player in the world Magnus
Carlson has dominated chess seemingly
forever but he's never played in the
bullet Chess Championship will one of
these big three of bullet take home the
twenty thousand dollar crown or can
someone else claim the title maybe Nara
ditsky Tang Hansen Carolina
that is the Fabiano finale in this
speediest of speech has championships
only one Champion will emerge
welcome to the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me is feed a master James
Kennedy III James we've had two very
exciting days of bullet chess thus far
four players have been eliminated how
you feeling about this competition
first off bullet chess is my favorite
format and I'm loving all the action
we're seeing we're seeing it in the chat
it's hype we seeing my brother my twin
brother Robert Heston we look just alike
chat you know that's my guy Robbie Bobby
right it's been great and the bullet's
been great I've been loving watching all
the games and we have some more today
Robert
oh we certainly do and some of these
players very well known because they're
in the upper echelons of the Chess World
others more known for their streaming
and content creation but as we look at
this bracket there are some surprises
and other results that we could have
expected and if we start at the top of
the bracket Hikaru Nakamura has moved on
he's taking on Daniel naroditski I think
Dania was the big winner of yesterday's
matches he beat Andrew Tang by eight
points that's not something you see
every day Magnus Carlson had his hands
full with streamer Min Lei Mana
Grandmaster from Vietnam he had that
match knotted up towards the very end
but Magnus was able to pull away for a
10-7 Victory and alireza farooza he made
it a short day against olezana Bortnick
he was in charge from the start and so
he gets to move on to face Magnus
Carlson we're excited about the top of
the bracket and the winners side of
things but we will start the day with
the losers bracket Bortnick against
Ohanian minlay against paravian Andrew
Tang against air Hanson James I think
that's one we have to Circle that's a
content creator Clash that everyone is
excited to see
absolutely the fastest man on the planet
man make sure you watch your wallet even
if you at home Tang boy play 15 second
chest okay and he's nice with it can you
have Eric Hansen of course who's had a
high of over 3K 31 3200 or something
crazy like that and bullet chess that's
gonna be a big Creator matchup and of
course who who doesn't want to see the
creators fight it out right that's
always us
yeah it might even be more fun if they
were chess boxing but we'll save that
for a later show this is the bullet
Chess Championship and we don't want to
leave out Jose Martinez and Dennis Las
Vegas they will also take part in the
losers bracket but we are going to start
our day with that Creator clash between
Andrew tang and Eric Hansen so these two
they're very familiar to the audience at
least they should be and on paper Tang
will have to be the favorite because he
is higher ridden bullet he's been an
absolute monster in bcc's past but we
haven't really seen Hanson play that
much because after losing the Opening
match to Magnus he had a walkover
against argentera geisey so we don't
know what Eric will show up
Eric is going to show up and because he
hasn't been able to play he had two
matches well of course he has been able
to play one was just you're playing
Magnus Carlson all right cool it is what
it is right now that's Magnus but then
you didn't have that other match he was
ready to really just kind of prove
yourself play some jazz that didn't
happen so now if I'm Eric I'm ready I'm
ready to really party boys let's get it
done so Eric definitely is gonna be uh I
think really ready to play today he
wasn't able to play against Magnus
obviously in that Arjun uh the origin
thing happens gonna be good though I
think Eric's ready uh he's always ready
to party that's for sure and you see
that Peak bullet rating of 32.65 that is
a very very high rating not many have
been able to reach that he is the
founder of the chess bras no surprise
there if you're watching this channel uh
you probably know who the chess bras are
over 100 million views on YouTube over
300 000 followers on Twitch but I think
James sometimes people forget he's not
just a content creator he's also a super
strong Grandmaster
bro he's the number one in Canada
wherever you are if you're the number
one I mean that's really good of course
and in a place like Canada you know us
Russia Australia wherever you are the
chess players how strong they are
absolutely being number one definitely
matters and he is the Canadian number
one so of course he's going to try to
you know try to put that uh together
today and he's in the losers bracket I
gotta make my way through everybody's
watching we're in Barcelona having a
good time hopefully today's a good time
yeah he hopes that it is but I think
somebody who's gonna make it a hard time
is Andrew Tang he is number one in the
hearts of many hyper bullet fans because
he does that blindfolded he's the
two-time BCC runner-up he lost to Hikaru
Nakamura last year in the Grand Final uh
he has over 3 million views on YouTube
he recently graduated from prison
University then took a trip with his
friends so he by his own admission has
been a little bit Rusty as it pertains
to Bullet chess but it's Andrew Tang all
right that's all that needs to be said
that's the penguin GM James
that was the penguin Jimmy of course
he's you know as we I saw that interview
he was so calm he was like yeah I mean
it's what I do I mean now he said moment
wait 10. how are you doing I just play
games and I'm gonna win I'm just gonna
do my thing
I stay sin I don't know I just don't
think about it that's uh that's that's
tame 100 as you see that's all it's
going through his head right now there's
no spatial Expressions even the smile he
does is very calm right so this man is
calm and he's mastered that and he can
go in here today and try to make it
happen again it
well you just reminded me of that Doc
Rivers interview on Jimmy Fallon where
he's talking about it's not Blake's
fault it's not Blake's fault you know
we've lost no teeth so that was awesome
but you're right you know Andrew Tang it
seems like he's unfazed no matter the
results of the match so he needs to win
this one you know it's your last bullet
if you're in the losers bracket so
there's a lot at stake it's not just oh
I lost a bullet game here I lost a
bullet game there my rating will suffer
the winner moves on the top eight and is
guaranteed four thousand dollars whereas
the loser is eliminated from the
competition and that means you gotta pay
they have 2500 that's a very nice payday
but 1500 difference that is a lot of
money
you can do always something with 1500
Extra of course that will help a lot
there but you also advance to the heat
which is huge here lots of people are
watching lots of pressure you want to
take it all the way to the top here
these guys are playing for more really
than just the money here I gotta put you
on the spot you know we're friends but I
have to put you on the spot who is going
to win this matchup
oh okay so that's a good one all right I
gotta go with I'm you know I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go with Eric I'm gonna go with
Eric because I have spent time at the
Jasper household I hang out with them
very good hospitality and Eric can shift
into another gear when he needs to
remember those boiler rooms they used to
do so I'm gonna go with Eric uh hands in
there on that one what about you hey
that's true loyalty because you're
saying I'm going with my guy I have to
go with the favorite on paper and that's
Andrew Tang he has been a runner-up and
two bullet chess Champions passed uh his
rating has often ballooned over 3 300
we've seen what he can do even with his
eyes closed in uh bullet chest so I
gotta go with Andrew But Eric you know
he is gonna try to make you proud
absolutely Eric Hanson the Manson and
Andrew tang with a bang that's how I
would always say talk about tank and he
definitely can come with a bang every
single time that boy plays But Eric does
have that gear it can you know make it
happen when he needs to especially Under
Pressure he is Canadian number one steal
right I think maybe a favorite on paper
but hey we'll see I think thing was a
favorite yesterday against niriditski
and that was crazy but I mean of course
this is bullet chess anything can
anything
it's true we have seen huge upsets in
the bullet Chess Championship yesterday
Amino hanyan he beat Anish Geary that
was surprising for many and the super
GMS Anish giri Fabiano caruana Dimitri
on Drake and they're all out of this
competition so it's not like having a
2700 rating next to your name means
you're automatically going to win yeah
if you're Magnus 2800 plus Hikaru and
farusha okay you get the job done
because you're the Final Bosses but it's
interesting to note that some of the
lower rated players they actually shine
in these quicker time controls
absolutely of course anything happens
when you reach this level and you have
the bullet it's bullet it happens they
go really fast obviously so it's really
I mean it's really it who is in good
form if you're in great form that day
you're just ready to go you can get it
done you are you know better than that
person really is what it takes
especially when you saw the near Disney
match yesterday that was just crazy
right and even seeing uh mindly versus
what versus Magnus oh Magnus gonna beat
them every game and it was not even
close to that so anything happens in
this format guys it's very fun to watch
there's a lot of time here too as well
so and it's win by two I like that
format and I could hear your heart in
that statement so it sounds like you
were particularly proud of men like it
sounds like him keeping it close with
Magnus that was a source of Pride for
you absolutely that's a win that's a win
on paper big men for the win the man one
day did you beat Magnus I mean I didn't
win the match but I won like what do you
mean like that doesn't make any sense
yeah but of course if you're men or if
you were watching you understand that
was a that was a win for men yesterday
so he told his head hi even though
Marissa he has to play on Dave Moravian
and then uh go over to see what happens
there so honestly if I'm in I'm on a
high like hey you know what I lost to
narrative I lost the Magnus here but I
mean that's that was close that's a
close match with Magnus not a blowout
what do you think I'm gonna do now
that's a great question and David
perovian doesn't want the answer to be
anything but hey you know take it easy
on me buddy I know you're super strong I
know you've got it going on you just
beat mags a bunch of times but let me
have my time to shine and we have such
great matchups even in the losers
bracket as we're looking down here Jose
Martinez against Dennis luzvick we
haven't spoken about that but then last
the upstart The Prodigy from Belarus
he's taking on a streaming sensation in
Johnson Jose Martinez who's won a couple
of bullet brawls and it seems like he's
always ready for a fight
yeah Dennis lastovic is I like the
fearlessness in it 17 going crazy
playing very strong chess he was
swinging and he uh down uh I think gear
no he took out Fabi it was just crazy
let's see Bobby Gold now Bobby's working
on his bullet too as well and me even
making it this far but then his loss of
it is showing some strength at this
young age here you have to show a lot
more though with the experience and
better and uh bullet player too as well
Grandmaster Jose Martinez they're gonna
be pulling it down
yeah Jose and he really is so strong in
this time control he's won two bullet
brawls and for those of you who are not
aware of bullet brawl these are happen
every Saturday and Hikaru Dania Bortnick
magnus's played you name these top
players especially in the bullet time
show they're in it tangas played but
Jasper Jose Martinez actually won two of
the events that is really impressive
stuff so do not count them out just
because he's in the losers bracket and
we won't count loves back out either
then last and he's a teenager his whole
career is ahead of him he is going to be
a star for many years to come so I'm
really stoked about this field four
players they were limited yesterday we
say goodbye to them but we're happy to
see the remaining contestants and Eric
Hansen versus Andrew Tang is going to
start shortly uh this is the bullet
Chess Championship which in the losers
bracket right now it Remains the format
of 30 minutes of play so as long as you
get that final game with one second on
the match clock that counts and James I
know you like sports the win by two
that's what we're using in the BCC this
year are you a fan of that indeed
absolutely I mean I remember playing you
know wreck ball I'm playing basketball
actually that's my favorite sport
outside that's there I don't watch it
because I'm just studying chess all the
time but basketball is like win by two
bro look oh we we have one yeah but it's
win by two like I just remember those
days playing basketball I'm like always
remembering it's win by two so we still
could win the game if we win by two
keeping that one you know point lead
it's not anything because you got to win
by two so that's very important I like
that it makes it really you have to beat
this guy by two games so it puts a more
you know fight into in you yeah you know
some good things happen in Streetball
but maybe we don't want to take the no
blood no foul rule into the Chess World
right this is how you played growing up
too
oh you know it was it was it was really
powerful like I'm just trying to play
basketball bro like relax right so it's
funny yeah so what it said that one by
two is gonna make it a completely
different game yeah down my head I
mentioned Doc Rivers before we're
talking about basketball now I'm just
thinking about those days you're like
you go for a lamp someone smacks you in
the back of the head so obviously you're
gonna miss the shot and they're like
yeah there's nothing play on you're like
you just gave me a concussion like that
is
what is this that's a foul my guy yeah
you have to be careful you're playing
basketball with guys so but it won't be
none of that today maybe just on the
boardwalk yeah you know there's
definitely gonna be some heavy swinging
we're starting with Andrew Tang versus
Eric Hanson but we do have many other
great matchups in store for you so if
you think that you're gonna leave after
tang and hence it you're wrong look at
this coming up right after the first
match it will be Jose Martinez against
Dennis luzwick and Min lay who proved
his might against Magnus Carlson
yesterday he takes on David paravian and
paravian has been under the radar but
really really good thus far he took a
bunch of games off of naroditsky then
again yesterday against ondraken that
was a one-sided matchup so paravian is a
name that you do not want to overlook
yeah actually you know I was talking
with Dania I was just in Charlotte I was
hanging out with Donya and board Nick so
just humble flex but also still chilling
with big homies there I was chilling
with them and they actually he was then
it was like yeah like Caribbean was just
better that he's playing good and if you
hear that from there ditchy you're like
oh he really playing good because he
actually gave him some props there said
that he was playing very good so
paravian is not someone who actually you
know uh take lightly in fact any none of
these matches you can take lightly but
definitely David if you're thinking he
was like oh who is that guy well that's
the same guy you know when you're waking
up like what happened what happened oh
you got knocked out oh because you
weren't paying attention
yeah he really is and well the final
match-ups of the day are names that I
think everyone they're gonna recognize
them they don't need any introduction
they're not being overlooked so you're
gonna be here all day let's be real
we're starting with Eric Hanson against
Andrew Tang but we're ending the day
with these matchups Magnus Carlson takes
on aleriza faruza Hikaru Nakamura
squares off against Daniel narodisky so
it's the prophet versus the final boss
in our latest matchup of the day and
then we got the world number one against
the anointed Challenger who didn't get
to challenge Magnus for the world
championship title in Ali Reza faruja so
James come on let's be real how pumped
are we for those two matches today
two words let's go is what I'm saying
Chad can we get it in there can we get
the energy in the chat right now where
are you Chad just let's just put this
energy up and get hyped for today
especially for these all the matches but
definitely today's winner semi-finals
there this is going to be epic
everybody's watching if you didn't take
off work tell your manager that you can
leave now no of course uh don't do that
but definitely if you've got to take our
work to watch this I mean or watch it on
your break because this is something you
just can't miss you just can't miss the
winter semifinal no you cannot and for
those of you who you know maybe paying
good attention good on you and notice
that the amino hanyan match was not
listed there it's because Ohanian is in
transit I believe and you're trying to
work on an agreeable schedule so he can
face off against Bortnick but that may
happen later in the day we'll keep you
posted on that but we are waiting on
Eric Hansen and Andrew Tang it seems
like Eric is having some connection
difficulties we don't want to start a
match until the players are set and you
know they have everything under control
because the worst thing that can happen
in bullet chess is you lose connection
the clock is running that wouldn't be
good news so hopefully Eric in Barcelona
everything is going okay there and James
you know we we mentioned at the end of
the day Magnus against alireza Hikaru
against Dania we have to start with the
earlier matches and we are excited about
those but I cannot wait for the winner
semi-final
bro that's gonna be it's exhilarating to
think about you dumb boys but they're
about to fight you're like oh yeah I
have something to do today I'm gonna
reschedule my flight you know what I
mean it's that serious to actually watch
these guys in action for 45 minutes
swinging and slugging it out for some
Championship spots so it's definitely
going to be the biggest thing the
biggest event right now around the world
and you know James you play a lot of
bullet first of all your Clips are
awesome I I go on Instagram like once a
day and then I just look and all of a
sudden they're just GM Canty
um videos popping up left and right and
I love them so what advice would you
give for people who are looking to
improve at bullet chess
absolutely you have to play it you have
to play I always say play it after like
an order breakfast lunch and dinner
right usually you should not be don't do
this at home if you're already doing it
it's fine don't do it anymore eating ice
cream then you eating pancakes and then
you eat like a steak and then you eat
cereal at night if this is your diet a
it is what it is but you need to fix
that around right we start with the
waffles and then you eat like you know
chicken is broccoli steak whatever you
eat and then at the end you do the ice
cream that's what bullet is bullet is
like that play it after you've done
everything the rest of the day study
some chess play some regular chess you
know look at things look at games and
then play some bullet chats but play a
lot of it 50 50 to 100 games maybe you
know a day if you can do that you got to
get the game wow so reps I mean that
doesn't surprise me me I've seen you at
the gym reps are important says James
candy and you know working on the
tactics is what we've heard and what's
been interesting to me has been noticing
how the players play when they have
about between 8 and 12 seconds because
some people they start pre-moving every
single turn but the best bullet players
they know exactly when to pre-move and
also when to make a bad move that can
catch their opponent off guard
absolutely this is a it's a bullet art
in fact I mean bullet chess my I haven't
I haven't reached three three k yet and
bullet I'm like 28 like 27.76 the
highest ever bullet for me but I do know
that you know it takes a lot of speed
and obviously knowing when you need to
do these weird pre-moves or when you
need to like oh man oh uh how did he
know the pre-move when he was going to
pre-move the pre-move like how did he
know this right this that's that's that
3K level and above which is very nice I
mean there's only it's a small group
chat on chess.com When You Reach 3K and
above and these guys are in and there's
a reason why Thunder is called the
prophet it's not for that's based on
earlier pop Champs event but it also
feels like he's prophetic when he's
playing bullet he just knows what his
opponent is going to do but he will need
to map out everything against Hikaru
Nakamura because Hikaru he is the
three-time bullet chess champion he's
won three of the four events here but
it's magnus's first time in the
competition and Magnus alireza Hikaru
done it there in the winter semis but we
are starting in the losers bracket you
lose you are done with this competition
is double elimination so for Eric Hansen
and Andrew Tang you cannot afford to
lose this matchup and Eric it seems like
he is getting everything under control
we saw him on camera he has switched his
connection either he switched his
location within his apartment there so
yeah I'm looking forward to this matchup
as it gets underway
okay Chad who y'all got Chad put it in
put one name Eric or tank put it in the
chat I want to see him I want to see him
flying in from wherever you are Eric
ortain put it in the chat it's about to
go down this is gonna be epic I'm going
with Eric and we see that Robert Hess is
going with the tank what do you got hey
I see hats okay
that one is excellent get that man a
diamond membership Eric Eric England
tank okay oh okay hey Eric Eric hang
with a bang nights Eric will get adopted
wow that one is that's crazy you gonna
put your house on that buddy
okay well we have tough one night right
like very nice very nice very active
watching all here with us it's going
down very soon here you know what's
funny is apparently the chat there's a
poll done and they said that bullet
chess is more fun to watch than
basketball so I mean you're on Twitch
that doesn't that doesn't really
surprise me that much but it's by a huge
margin so many more people prefer
watching bullet than basketball uh yeah
I don't know it seems like you do as
well James here said you don't watch
basketball but you love to play
absolutely what about bullet basket what
the heck would that look like you just
have to always move fast you just can't
slow down maybe you got time to do
something get shots off that's cool
maybe we'll try that maybe it's uh yeah
chess comb let's hit that basketball and
pull the chest see how that works and
the clock has started timer up there
do we have moved it looks like we donut
moves just yet but hopefully they come
in soon as the players get underway uh
but you know what you said movie
Non-Stop basketball just sounds like
Russell Westbrook so you know or D rode
right oh yeah early D Rose before his
knee injuries
this match hopefully uh is getting
underway in a moment here we'll try to
bring up the moves as they are played
but it's going to be a good one I'm just
you know ready for it already like come
on stop it's like pre-used the movie
theater we don't need all these trailers
for all these other movies just show me
the movie that I just came here to watch
I just want to see the movie man come on
bro dang come on trying to play I'm
gonna play guys and we're gonna have the
game up in a minute it's gonna be fun to
watch uh see chess says chassis has a
West brick
and I wasn't gonna say it so you know
that's not my fault yeah that's the
blame chat right always blame chat if
you lose a game you blame chat you know
if you blunder your queen yeah you
distracted me Chad but we are in the
thick of this first game James and well
Andrew has the white pieces Eric with
black has the isolated Pawn I would say
Advantage tank
definitely I do like uh with tank play
or while the engine goes all the way up
and you see a lot of this anyway like
it's even hard to even analyze sometimes
because you'll be like and then but then
oh okay mate yeah maybe yes right that's
how fast it goes right but yeah
definitely white has a clear Advantage
here I wonder if this was a Londoner
yeah
I was gonna say it's tank so I assume it
is but right now all I see is the light
Square weaknesses for Eric and that
Knight went in now it's two Bishops
against two knights White's also up a
pawn this is pretty much as bad as it
gets for Hanson
hey thanks
who we yeah Bishop's looking good there
oh wow oh shoot okay right back in the
game for sure yeah wow time you always
say James the 17th piece I think in
bullets like the fourth piece
yeah
right uh we got Bishops pawns Bishops
Knights uh clock work
that's so funny but yeah yeah that's
that's correct here you have to be so
fast it doesn't matter I say this all
the time
um on stream too it doesn't matter how
you get it it matters if you got it done
if somebody's coming in here and they
see oh what's the score they see things
up again they didn't see that he flagged
they might have even lost the game they
should see that he's up the game that's
what really matters here it doesn't
matter you get it you get it done 100
yeah
I see the Evo bar but I'm looking at the
king safety and I'm like black in bullet
has to win this kind of position a lot
of the time but now that the queen moved
out the E5 Pawn could that have been
captured just a moment ago it's too hard
as you said to calculate everything and
even get our words out
yeah it's two it's always too fast too
fast and two Furies here Queen A7 G4
whoa takes takes
okay well it's like the same thing well
yeah Eric's doing well right yeah he
stole a pawn like suddenly whites up a
pawn White's King is perfectly safe
because the Queen's off the board and
look at the clock I wasn't expecting to
see Eric up so much time it Tang is the
faster player between the two but Eric
understands that if he is going to win
this match he needs to keep steady on
the clock
you also uh it's striking like when you
get hit once you like all right I'm just
mad so I think I can feel the energy on
Eric right now he's pissed about that
last game that he was winning and got
flagged kind of season's face a little
bit and he's moving very fast and he's
being accurate got the time Edge a
little bit you know he's up something
he's feels like he's in the zone right
here in this game yeah right now it
looks like Tang he's you know he's
trying to keep this about at the same
Pace but I feel like Tang's just a
little bit faster in making these
decisions you see the advantage it's all
the way up there for white but white is
down on the clock
white is down on the clock that's
important he gotta move
okay check oh discover check blunder
your Bishop
oh my goodness yeah here go tang and now
here come the 15 second part this hurts
oh but he's back in the game boy all
these three moves caught the pre-moves
and flags
[Music]
James I think that's what we're going to
be seeing in this match hold on let me
stand up
real quick bro hold on relax dog look at
him standing up wow
yeah he's not happy you saw the head
shake there he is unhappy about that
game
oh yeah you don't like me when I'm angry
you don't like me when I stand up boy oh
wait that is crazy speaking of crazy
this is a crazy London system where
White's going all in on the king side
attack and black is trying to trade off
that good light Square bishop and what
do you think James the open G file looks
scary at first glance but you don't have
enough peace in the attack
yeah I mean it's coming though Knight D4
this was like some type of Joe Baba in
fact you know me and Jar Jar Binks
London but it does uh yeah Bishop A6 oh
wow Bishop 80 just moves out the way I
wanted to double the Rooks but I can't
because the B Pawn so he's gonna try to
work that maybe bishop or F for even
better now I can double A3 first very
accurate maybe B4 now or B3 would be
something you want to double these rows
he's trying but you gotta there it is B3
and then double and then try to make try
that's the question yeah but he's on it
I don't think he's gonna succeed look at
Black's Rooks and Bishop all guarding
the G7 pawn and the queen came back to
defend as well I feel like Eric has done
a perfect job of Defending and the clock
Eric's up 10 seconds
here we go takes takes Queen takes
mm-hmm
oh yeah he's down a piece here oh wait
what's the okay wasn't E3 just hang in
there with check and that would
definitely bro check me take on E3
thanks
oh
hey Rook G5 take space what's the time
he's up time
cleaning up there it is clinical
clinical
Eric that was a dominating performance
in game three he was down by two and he
needed that win and he got it so hey
James you picked him and he's saying I'm
gonna try to make you feel like your
pick was worth it and now it's two to
one and Eric he was speeding up and that
was most important
yeah he stood up too he stood up and
everything got different he just stood
up and it was a different game he just
stood up hey you know let me stand up on
your young fella and then uh it worked
right so of course anything that does
work there even sometimes in term
engagement like you lose with a certain
shirt on you're like man this is a
stupid shirt's fault you know so he
stands up here and uh he's going to work
now with the white pieces there got to
be faster you fight both games again you
see with the white piece he's up a pawn
and he can grab a second pawn and he
does and he said I don't believe in your
attack but I typically do believe in the
attack in bullet chess people make
mistakes when their kings are
endangering classical chess but in
bullet you get nervous but what I love
about what Eric has done he stood up and
then he started playing faster and
faster and he's currently up 10 plus
seconds
that's crazy that is a lot of time for
real look how much time you have this is
amazing and he got his great position
too as well
can you take a third Pawn on D5 I would
be a little bit nervous maybe I'll play
Queen G2 save my king you know that's
the most important thing he goes to open
file can't blame for that so Tang is
desperately trying to attack the white
king but so far there are enough
defenders in front of it
let's see uh okay oh White's winning
Queen G2 takes takes I got enough pawns
I'm good this should be a clean one you
also got D5 coming he stops it with
Bishop a seven takes there it is yeah
there it is appreciate it Bishop takes
takes takes Rook D1 very easy here very
easy but you gotta be fast yeah he's up
enough time that's the good news and
he's also up three pawns I don't think
we've uh seen that very often but here
they come one at a time and what Eric
needs to do is stop trying to be perfect
just make quick moves we saw what Andrew
did is he would give away pieces because
it would take two three seconds off
Eric's clock Eric is getting this one
done oh okay that was one of those
moments where the Rook looked loose for
a second uh but no he has everything
under control
yeah this is it oh Eric Hansen the
little dance little Shuffle there little
dad boss Shuffle as he calls it and he
gets back to work wow I mean just P2 now
we have our Enzo Indian is two to two
after that one very nice and well Andrew
tank Strang from the London that's a bit
surprising because it's his tried and
true weapon in the opening and Eric
strikes in the center while Tang attacks
on the king side this is gonna be a fun
match
it's gonna be a fun game too as well
okay Rook G1 there it is Rook G1 Knight
F5 is not happening Eric is not with any
of that action stops everything
84 that's a very strong move definitely
like blacks initiative already got a
castle though passing police side
probably next move yeah so he takes this
nice the Senate watch out for the G7
square look at that Queen on E5 what you
gonna do James how are you gonna attack
me I'm not in fact he said get him off
the board 97 though white has Vantage he
said exactly I don't care about none of
that
wow that was a great move
and that's a great move by Tank Rook G5
you attack the C5 pod answer to push
your own Pawn to F5 so Eric gives it up
he says look I have to stop F5 my king
would be too vulnerable but the king
looks in a bit of an iffy spot on F6 as
well
thanks
five not a piece
anything
um
you know I actually think that is a
likely result with a king I mean Rook F2
King D3 but where is that white king
escaping to it's definitely difficult
there's some mating ideas especially
with the bishop and the rook and the
King very close I guess I run the king
up to A3 though believe it or not
checking air check in there checking
there I'm out the way I literally run
away it's A3 which he's done yep and
pain and wind GG get him off the board
oh my goodness and Andrew kept that lead
on the clock and did the extra exchange
it was the perfect combination to get
that Victory so three two for tank he is
able to rebound after consecutive losses
and now we have a French defense what is
happening here
press defense isn't bullet or against
strong players is really difficult not
the easiest but definitely uh it's solid
you can get moves off really quickly but
then you realize wait I have to defend
the rest of the game now because that's
on the Friendship especially when you
get attacked like these guys are doing
right now yeah but quickly was the
operative word look at the clock tang
with the black pieces he's up seven
seconds but Queen H4 Knight takes F7
anybody we're helped by the evaluation
bar it went all the way up Knight takes
F7 sacrifice a move ago that would have
hurt Tang his king would have been
vulnerable
absolutely you gotta watch out for these
sacrifices of course H7 is a thing too
as well at night at four he takes it
we're gonna take with the queen he says
no there's nothing I don't have anything
oh yeah no taste was a thunder this
would be seven which steals play but he
did it this way and nine
yeah
do you want to take C2 but then F7 drops
that's why tank spent some time in Barth
King back to G8 keeping F7 defendant but
C3 keeps the queen side defendant so we
have even material but that Bishop on B7
an absolute monster the Knight goes up
to D4 to avoid The Bishop's gaze and I
think that here we see that black would
like an attack but where is it coming
from
yeah H4 he's getting attacked in fact H4
you got to move the Rook away okay it
could go somewhere wow engine but evil
bar really hated that what do they have
oh check in Rook E5 wins the bishop oh
my goodness that was sick yeah you'll be
able to survive
uh wait that Rook on G6 is Adam moves
it's like it's trapped
Bishop B3 whoa what a move but there's
still a lot of moves there okay that was
sick nice fine that really was and it
looks like the black king should be in
some danger but the white king is also
out in the open E3 check wouldn't
surprise me and by the way look at the
time both players down to their final
seconds
here we go this is chaos nh4 very quick
from Tang Black's just winning F4 wins
no it doesn't check first that's even
more accurate takes takes takes on you
down a piece and that's a wrap
3.8 seconds was the difference in that
game and it's what Andrew needed to win
it he was also a material but the time
was the deciding factor so we see him
look at this bizarre opening G4 on move
two
um I would say that Tang is tilting but
he just won two games in a row
oh no this is uh is this this in the
files what I mean by that is this is
just an aggressive files 101. at some
point in every game with the white
pieces you have to play G4 that's what
it says the aggressive attacking manual
okay yeah
or a certain move so very nice I I
approve 100
how is this possibly working out for
white like if you're watching please
don't play with yourself don't go to
your next tournament and start playing
G4 move two yeah this is just wild so I
feel like White's Kings should be
checkmated soon but trading Queens yeah
it's no longer going to be made not the
move you're also a head shake there
immediately from from Hanson they're
moving a little bit too quickly and
moving I mean trading Queens I mean now
I'm fine I'm even better right you have
this pressure on the king side I have to
somehow make the bishop and F5 is a very
good beat okay E4 apparently a mistake
maybe since the E4 Pawn was loose Knight
G6 was available now it's defended so
yeah this looks really really strong for
uh Tang especially if you can get his
other Rook jump that Rook to H1 there's
gonna be a barrel down the H file and
the black King's in trouble
absolutely yeah King Eve whoa relax
breathe hold on we got kids why
that's horse mate that's game that was
sick
oh
whoa
that's a nasty one
and Eric now with the white pieces down
five to two we see a French once again
if it worked the last time why play
something different and I just think
this match it's not already a foregone
conclusion but if he doesn't get this
one I think Tang will be feeling all the
confidence
especially after a blow like that when
you get hit like that like you know it's
like boxing too like when you get hit
and you get days that's when they just
jump on you because your knees starting
to buckle a little bit and you like whoa
and this this guy hit kind of hard that
actually hurts a little bit and you it's
no recovery time you just have to play
the next game so if he Hanson has to
recover that's what it is stop the
bleeding here
well that's why he went Bishop takes d8
you know he said I see that coming I'm
gonna avoid it this time uh but they're
clearly are some tactics in the position
Knight D7 was a great move and after you
oh Queen D3 at the end trade Rooks and
queen D3 oh it's a peace peace wait well
I mean okay yeah it just gets the king
well Bishop F6 though check check and
then uh the king runs away we have
Bishop D6 I think anyway
nice move though look at that Retreat
that's what I didn't see I thought yeah
I thought queen of seven you win you win
a pawn but he goes Bishop B4 first and
now Queen E6 take all the Pawns sjg
actually But Here We Go Eric needs this
yeah go back to F7 go back to F7
repeat Bishop takes a oh no that's made
yes you get nated Boy watch the mate is
on G2 there is made on G2 Bishop D6
check the king can't go to A7 because
Bishop E4 Queen E8 check Queen oh blocks
of the bishop wasn't expecting that
Eric's taking everything oh give me
everything
I just noticed Eric's down to five
seconds Gotta Move now and this is not
the guy to be down that much time on
oh he's not trading them quickly enough
he needs to get those last pawns off the
board he's not gonna do it
annoying how he flagged him how do you
do this he's so kind of now
mix me up when you do that's so funny
but it's so true like he just does not
react you never know how good his
position is because he keeps himself
very collected every single move just
Andrew tang and he's now Up by Four
Points in this match it was two to two
now it's ballooned to six to two and
apparently some mistakes have just
happened
oh there's G5 I think
oh it was he actually sat back down to
as well he's like all right let me sit
down hold on bro let me get a hold of
this let me get my feet together he sat
down there and trying to figure this out
he is starting to run away with it is
four to two now he did score obviously
more or here in the Magnus thing but
there's lots of games and it's the fight
if he UPS the speed it's different but
then you the accuracy goes down to as
well which is natural
yeah I don't even know if he sat down or
tank sat him down because it's been that
kind of match right now where tanks like
I'm in control of this and you're gonna
do as I say but this position there's a
knight on D6 it's an outpost square
there's another D5 it's also now post
but look at the black king Suddenly It's
in some serious Danger
yeah definitely so I'm serious oh we
hitting bro he's finding everything
right now he's finding everything oh my
goodness I gotta walk away from him in
the rougher he's hungry you know he went
to Princeton he is a tiger he is just
clawing at Eric Hansen's King right now
and it looks like there should be a
Checkmate in the near future
easy yep here it is we're G6 another
brilliant move this is nasty right now
this is this this is clinical we gotta
wake up Eric we gotta wake up right now
yeah you know wow they take siestas in
Barcelona but now is not the time for
one of those you gotta play quickly and
you have to play well right now Eric is
up time and I do think that's going to
be more important for him because Andrew
just keeps blitzing him I mean that's
not bliss's bullet just he's moving so
quickly that Eric just doesn't even have
the time to calculate anything
right yeah it's important you got to be
able to calculate boys and girls right
and you got to be able to calculate well
at that
here
James again I'm back okay look at this
look at this position I mean wow
this is sad
it's gross
what are my pieces doing
I don't have the answer for that but it
does appear that uh suddenly Eric back
in the game according to the evaluation
bar and also just by the time Eric is
now well ahead in the clock and this is
the pace that he needs
yeah well okay we got something he has
some yeah this is okay he's gonna play
E3 at some point you know E3 is coming
oh yeah there it is
Queen takes D4 just sack the bishop and
just play look at look at the clock
James it's an extra about 12 seconds for
Hansen this is speed that's what he
needs he needs he needs a Need for Speed
here you got to be very quick gotta
trade Queens that's Force goodness the
speed doesn't even help like you move
faster you're still losing this this is
uh it's very hard to play the fight he's
in excellent more he's in excellent form
right now this is the thing that you saw
to make it to the finals would be near
this heat and this he got him this time
but definitely this tank did not like
losing and they're ditchy here and he
might be taking it out on this uh
yeah I'm looking the clock though Tang
down to seven seconds he's up a piece
that's the good news and you might throw
it a couple checks if you get them look
at that premium King G6 he knew G4 is
coming this is what we talk about the
best players the best bullet players
they know what's coming and when the
pre-move oh oh man
I'm back in the game
wait what happened
yeah you're like hold on let me let me
let me get the mouse together let me
regroup let me hold on you see him
grabbing the mouse like it's just crazy
bro how fast you have to be with this
guy
yeah and that's the thing right you're
like look at my mouse what's wrong with
you and really what's wrong is that the
opponent is so strong and Andrew has the
white pieces in this game
and so he is in charge and up eight to
two he's got his system the London in
place Rook lift James this is definitely
your type of game
do you even Rook lift first off secondly
this is a very fun attack that you have
me oh yeah Queen's coming to H4 H5 is
going to be played there it is Queen H4
G4 can be next here but they might meet
that with Rook eight eight
B5 Knight E4 okay so he doesn't go for
it oh he's gonna sack on F7 Here Comes
oh my goodness this is over man we're
going back to playing this what might
take steps F7 and then 96. come on boy I
mean this is tactics it's supposed to
Res you called it you just said bring
all the pieces forward and there's got
to be something you just like name a
move at some point and it's gonna happen
so H3 just Aces off the board yeah
thanks thanks
nah
this is this oh when it works this
opening can be very very deadly here and
it actually looked like sort of A nimso
Larson that you can get with Knight F3
B3 Bishop B2 or Kali e3d495 Edition
right the regular stuff but they came
from a London which was like really in
the sick he loves me
he loves it he is a star in that opening
and well look at the dark Square
domination the F4 G3 whoa
oh it's my legs bro chill bro
we gotta did y'all check his uh y'all
check his task manager right yeah
I think chesscom checks the task manager
makes you don't have any programs
running in the background oh yeah they
do the only program he has in his head
and it's just one that you know
sometimes it feels like a Rivals
stockfish and Leela and all that Andrew
Tang is just obliterating Hanson in this
match and of course with all respect to
the chess bro uh Eric Hansen but this is
just a great bullet chess and when
you're seeing greatness unfold you just
have to say yeah I appreciate that this
is really cool
yeah I mean this is dominated I mean
really what it takes is you have to stop
the bleeding what is that which is
happening right now very good if he can
get a win you can breathe all right I'm
good you breathe yes it's not over a lot
of Chess and like you know it hurts to
lose like this obviously you know no
matter who you are but you can stop the
bleeding bro like you feel a little bit
better and there's quite a double
question
yeah both sides yeah exactly we have a
piece now it's so two pieces for a rook
but this is past a pawn really hard to
calculate who's better with the eval
bars it's doing that seesaw you know
it's doing uh the bench press up and
down up and down but it looks suddenly
like black he's doing really well that
past Pawn won't be stopped Knight B3
works oh yeah even better but Rick sakes
saying Rick C1 is oh man he even doing
it the clinical way the 3300 way he
could have did like you know uh Rook
Rook Place B3 Rook C1 which is really
cool but also uh
this way the very very okay maybe he got
some play here Chase takes
clock that's what that's what Eric's
hoping for oh but Rook takes C4 oh and
then that Bishop only one was hanging
good good find by Eric he's keeping this
complicated but Andrew has been the
faster player so now we're into a real
scramble territory let's see if Eric can
make it work it doesn't look like it
he's spending more time
yeah F5 you want him he's on him but I
do like the Tango here the little
dancing that the pieces are doing the
miners he has
very nice little Tango this should be
one and it takes I run the king up I am
lost okay I see you the Tango that's
good I see what you did there a little
Tango you know the little Tango the
little salsa dance with the dad bod
Shuffle
hey man the Andrew Tango maybe he's
getting a new nickname so you know he's
just through Tango you know
unfortunately for Eric it's one of those
situations where it's just you can't
stop the guy when Andrew Tang is in this
kind of form there are just a handful of
people who can keep pace and
unfortunately for Erica this is just one
of the toughest opponents on the planet
and this game also going Andrew's way
yes it's that it's very difficult I mean
as uh Eric's 3K bully but it's just I
mean 300 points more here with with
paying it's just insane Tang is
absolutely a monster you're losing in
the day it shows you how strong your
discus too like I mean from there disc
you to score what happened yesterday and
that score with against hey and they're
like that's just letting you know
obviously uh near discus playing on
another level today too we're gonna see
him later on but Tang is showing a
dominating performance here and Eric
needs to stop the bleeding is that eight
games in a row here Robert uh I believe
so and also now it's about to be nine he
just dropped the bishop D7 at the end
and Eric just shakes his head like kind
of like yep I missed that one and this
this is gonna hurt yeah
adoption like Eric adoption and I
laughed at that but I mean
that this is very close
I did not think it was gonna happen I
mean I just didn't I don't think many
people thought that it will adoption
would happen I leave for five minutes
and it's 10-2 near Disney in the chat
yeah it's crazy Nero what's what is he
doing there this he mad he's mad for
what you did too this is Daniel's fault
I think we can all agree on that but
Donya you did this you unleashed the
angry tang and as James says he's always
calm he's always just very stoic but now
he's mad and he's taken out on Hanson
yeah it was rice Mary's in Mary Zen and
Mary call very calm
[Laughter]
it's so funny and he's you know he's
gonna make quick moves doesn't matter if
they're good moves at this point he's up
uh four seconds and he's going to win on
the clock and there it is 3.9 in the end
so it's now 11 to 2 uh the match
obviously is over in terms of the
overall winner but this could be a 10th
straight win if Andrew gets it done with
black yeah that's crazy I really thought
there was adoption wasn't possible with
Eric playing bullet here like you know
nah he's not gonna adopt them I mean but
this is the adoption game
and Eric needs to win this or like just
he got adopted I mean I'm I'm honestly
like shocked that even happened here is
it showing how strong this man is right
now uh thing that is Chad says tangry
he's tangry you know oh yeah that's a
good one that's a great one and you know
it's kind of what you were saying that
sometimes when um you know someone loses
all these games in a row people in the
chat they like to make fun of the the
person who's losing but I think we just
have to say how well Andrew Tang is
playing like that's why Eric is losing
it's like Eric's playing badly it's just
Tang is faster Tank's finding sick Rook
sacks and all these checkmating ideas
and speaking of checkmating ideas look
at things push all these pieces up in
front of the king yeah and Tang is him
he's in his own exact so you know you
don't just get a 3 300 bullet rate near
3K you don't just get either I mean Eric
Hansen has a very nasty rating high of
32-56 actually so close to 3 300 but I
think tanks may have been higher at that
point 32-56 tank might have been 3 400
probably but it's a it's another level
right now hang is you can see he is very
common to it in every game I mean I
think he had one blip where he was like
whoa actually earlier in this game but
now
yeah any oh he removes the Knight and
just is the position's closing on the
king so that's good news for Eric the
bad news is oh he just made some kind of
f2's hanging right isn't that just
shook his head there wait what happened
oh he's still his move yeah oh man
that's an adoption he got adopted
[Music]
you could do it like mine doesn't do it
to everybody besides like he car room
like a few others but he got adopted bro
that is crazy that like shocks me and
what's this oh my God I'm out of here
man look hey you on your own Robert this
is this is I got about to go call them
people
hello yeah I got a recorder
you know that game that just ended that
was actually crazy and I think we should
show that after this match it concludes
what we have a second because it was a
very short game and we can explain why
Eric resigned but that was just really
what's happening today I have no words
for it it's just Andrew Tang is in
Stellar form he's not won 11 games in a
row
I mean honestly especially the way that
that happened it was like a 12 second
game the one that he just lost it is a
tilt here and it happens especially when
you lose many games in a row it just
hurts bro it hurts it hurts here he has
something he has Knight B3 now finally
he can get something now you just want
to see the man get a game and I think he
might get one here Bishop takes E5 with
hitting mate The Rook hanging in the
corner there's a little bit from from
Andrew Taylor saying yeah that was gross
that one you can't if he win this one I
mean it should be like a mercy rule like
yo I'm out you know can I just leave the
match right if you can't win this one
right so visitation taking V8 like I'm
winning all this material I should be
able to be able
under 40 seconds uh in this match
remains so if somehow Andrew can keep
this game going he may see this to be
the last game otherwise he'll have to
play one more uh but yeah he resigned
yeah this one is completely busted for
him and he's down the clock so the next
game will be our final one
yes uh yeah I mean shoot if I'm Eric I'm
just happy to get out of this you know
what it is what it is okay Tang you know
you lose to taking it like Tang is is
very fast and we know him for what he
does so great you know what I mean like
you you still can hold your head high
here it's just you want us to do more in
this match totally understand
and we see Tang you know going for one
of these D4 setups he's just doing his
thing and he pushes in the center now it
looks great for white keep pushing those
pawns I think we're going to see another
huge attack
absolutely F4 right he plays London on
an all-time format it's classical it
doesn't matter he just loves this London
system here I'm gonna sing with the jar
jar being Java London love playing it F6
and G6 that makes some weakness attacks
H4 H5 G4 what the heck is that yeah C4
is a blunder oh yeah yeah obviously open
the king you know yeah the knight's
gonna come in at some point Knight G3
not up to have five H6 is loose maybe
the queen would like to join the party
for white
yeah GG I guess it's nice has something
more accurate G7 Queen H5 H4 though oh
nice move because now H4 the Knight
moves out the way somewhere I don't know
where I'm at Knight 65.
his Knight takes E5 a thing here yeah 90
but then takes and he takes on G7 what
is going on in calculation
oh apparently that was a gaming Knight
F3 check or something
this is so confusing right right that's
really one-on-one
and now it's back to winning for white
or that's what happens at bullet also
Andrews up a lot of time so uh yeah
maybe not the perfect game but still a
game that it appears he's gonna take
April H6 and Gigi
yeah that is the match Andrew Tang moves
on guarantees himself at least four
thousand dollars in prize money and at
minimum uh top eight finish so
congratulations to Andrew it's
unfortunate that Eric had to be the
player who is going home a lot of fans
out there for the chess bra but I think
with this match now in the books we just
have to clap for Andrew Tang that was a
masterful performance very masterful
right I'm very stoic I mean yeah I just
got in the flow I lost two games and I
got in the flow and I did better and
yeah I'm just gonna keep playing and
help for the best he did very good here
shout out to tang and dominating
performance today that's what he does
right and uh he lost it they lose it in
there ditski was like he just really
woke up in this match here's aggressive
for sure so Andrew tank moves on and
that means that we know one player who
is going to be in the losers bracket
round three that's Andrew Tang but we
still have more matches in round two
coming up so it's going to be really a
long day of Chess but a fun day of Chess
here in the bullet Chess Championship
and with that we're gonna have to Scurry
on over to a break we don't have time
for anything but that because we'll get
right back into the BCC matches win
return in just a few moments
Jess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing the
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Jose Martinez Grandmaster from Peru he
lost yesterday's matchup to Hikaru
Nakamura but he is about to square off
against Dennis luzvick in the losers
bracket second round superstar in his
own right two-time champion of bullet
brawl James you think he's ready for
today
oh he definitely but you can see the
face he's focused that man's ready to go
he doesn't like losing I don't think
anybody does because at this level here
the man locked in the room you see how
clean that room was he focused the room
super clean the door altered and locked
you can't get out unless you get to eat
do all this other stuff and do a
backflip right the man is locked in
right now so it's going to be nice to
see a lock me and Jose Martinez versus a
very young and strong in this last one
yeah if anyone can get past a player
like Jose it's someone like Dennis
luzvick who took down Fabiano caruana
yesterday that was a very interesting
matchup between the youngster who was
leading and then lost a couple games but
was able to write the ship at a critical
moment we'll also have Min lay taking on
David paravian minlay a hero he's like
the people's Champion right now because
he went Toe to Toe with the giant that
is Magnus Carlsen it was even for a long
portion of that match before Magnus was
able to pull away with a three-point
match Victory so uh you know Min he is
definitely somebody you want to keep
your eyes on but as we keep saying don't
overlook David perovian he says uh men
always like I'm so wholesome you're so
wholesome that's what he likes to say a
lot and you never can say anything bad
about minlay I mean he's just very
wholesome right when you watch his
streams you just all love there like you
can't not love the guy and big men for
the win did his thing against Magnus
yeah you're playing Magnus I'm if I'm
him I'm feeling very confident in fact
maybe even a close number two or three
obviously carlosia I'm feeling really
good after you know hanging with Magnus
the way that he did so going into this
next match I have a lot of confidence
well with that painting behind you it's
always a wonderful time and minlay
that's his username that's his stretch
he's getting ready to go like this is a
sporting battle he wants to win he wants
to move on uh he wants to better his
performance from a year ago and if
yesterday was any indication the way he
played against Magnus was superb and
David paravin will have his work cut out
for him
you know what's funny I think they uh I
think they both they've played before
and it's more of like the hair Twirls
wouldn't this yeah exactly the Heritage
World Championship with them boys like
Manley and David fragon both I think it
was both swollen at the same time any
Beaufort glasses and he throw it in the
same direction it was like
you're totally right they are two of the
most prolific hair twirlers in the Chess
World and there are many uh but we see
that both matches are underway on the
left side seems early going there oh
Knight takes D5 by Jose Martinez on the
left-hand side screen that was a
tactical shot winning a pawn in the
middle and on the right hand side of our
screen we see that men with the white
pieces he's getting his system James you
know he loves these types of positions
absolutely those londons are very very
strong I mean he's a London system
player too as well you saw what tank
just did here with some London's I mean
men does the same thing too many strong
players with the London system right
even I mean got a camski right a famous
fun Legend there you know he actually
likes the London as well too he's like
the London system in games always favor
white all these people that like the
London even Magnus crossing the queen G3
oh my goodness oh it's off the board get
him off the board what is he doing
what is he doing
right hand side of your screen and now
the queen has fully infiltrated so black
has too many pieces for Rook but most
importantly Dave Robin has an attack and
has enough time to execute it
him off the board okay you gotta warm up
here my guy did we do did you do some
puzzle rest amen you got to do some
puzzle wrestler or something today that
one definitely hurt uh and then David
probably didn't miss a beat there well
warm-ups you know they should help you
but Jose warmed up by playing in Arena
Kings he started with a perfect 10 out
of 10 but in this first game against
Dennis luzovich he's down in exchange so
he's down on the clock he's down in
exchange on the board but he just got
his exchange
he's like oh I'm good man shoot I gotta
you know get the Jitters out is what
this is a little bit about is getting
the Jitters out a lot of times iterate
oh man I'm playing this new person today
and then you you get in the swing of
things I think Dania said it best too as
well like when you have uh when games
are being played in those first moves
once you first get the moves off some
few games then the Jitters go away you
just back
well we saw a draw in the game between
Jose and Dennis so you know fine start
for both of them and a Checkmate there
for David paravian against Min Le men
will definitely be disappointed by that
start he overlooked a tactic in front of
his King and that cost him the first
game so we see so I'm saying mid slow
start but how to get the handicap out of
the way I don't think that you are
giving any handicaps to David pravin we
saw how he continued with Dania and then
how he beat him and draken so yeah you
do not want to be down against him
no yeah you're not giving any of that
and uh it's definitely Scandinavian land
for man he's been playing a salon
license type of positions but I mean I'm
like Davis read my messages I mean he's
in great France this is a scary David
right now I'm not even gonna lie this is
a very aggressive test definitely a fan
of it relax bro chill
hey man David relax bro wow he is really
coming in man yeah what is that he just
C4 coming up next on the right hand side
of your screen he's gonna win that pin
Knight on D5 so what a start for David
paravian and on the left-hand side
screen looks like Jose Martinez is up a
minor piece against Dennis loveswick I
see an extra Knight but that Queen
infiltrating and the Beast oh gosh what
a fine by Jose there
give me the queen I appreciate it thanks
for the generosity and we keep moving
yeah he's moving in the center he's
opening it up for the Queen the queen
needs that space otherwise that past
seat Punk could be dangerous and we see
that David breaking things open for his
pieces as well men fighting very
carefully
yeah g7's hanging then we move the queen
and then we Queen
oh before it comes back
pushing no mate check I'm off the way
have a nice day and some work C4 Queen
check in spicy boys check what do we do
check again
and King D6 blade
you win
let me take on D5 you don't even need to
yeah everything's pinned up what is this
a draw what there might have been Rook
takes Rook with Queen C4 check to follow
but now white oh man you're right no I
look at Men's clock by the way man on
the right hand side he is down on time
against paravian and by the way Jose
Martinez did win that game and oh that's
checking mate that's mate
David relax hey man that boy is going
crazy
that was Dick whoa sometimes it's nice
to be the underdog right everyone's
talking about how men was doing so well
against Magnus he's the person to beat
in this match and Dave's like I'm here
and I'll just let my moves do the
talking
right he's like oh okay y'all want to
talk about man y'all ain't talking about
David cool no problem he's uh proceeded
to start working I mean he's definitely
putting on a show right now you're gonna
expect it to see men being down two in
the first two games but it's only two
games without a lot of chips and a lot
of hair twirling right now for men so
there it is it started James you called
out for it and it has begun he's doing
beard twirling beer Twirls in the
character you know what I'm saying he
gotta twirl something I even got the two
pawns right they always spawn checked me
I got this on stream we always have two
pawns at all times right no matter where
I am I always got two content if you
ever see me but I do twirl of course you
do the pawn twirl all players do
something oh throw this on look at him
twirl his fingers now oh um twirl his
Queen next to his opponent's king and
deliver Checkmate that was nasty yo that
was nasty man is finally feeling a
little better there it's nice you can
breathe this is what you need stop the
bleeding and then all right proceed to
work so he's back in the game the other
matchup you know has also going on still
just keep everyone updated is a draw in
the third game so it is two to one in
Jose Martinez favor but in this game
this looks so solid that's why he played
these scandies he gets into his comfort
zones where you may not play that In
classical chess but when there's not
much time he's like I know that I don't
have any easy targets right it's a
really annoying effect uh playing
against scandy when when you win the
scandi players get their positions
meaning very solid
and do anything and now you reach an end
game they trade all the pieces and then
you lose like the psychological Factor
hits did we think I was trying to crush
this opening now we're in an end game
that's equal now they're better like
right and that's very nice is min style
100 for this format as well before they
take take over E4 right yeah he wants to
keep pieces on it it would seem and and
for anyone who tells you that multitask
is a myth you know look at men
multitasking the hair twirling is
getting quicker and quicker the players
spinning up yeah this is and this is
honestly very impressive here but David
I mean look at the way he's playing now
we're in equal end game he's actually
the one who's slightly ahead on the
clock and well mince King is active in
hiding in front of the pawn both sides
need to be careful here
both sides do need to be careful a lot
of times these do favor black but on
these like you know these just the
scandi are we're like okay the opening
was a success for Scandinavian players
right we used to end in game but this
should be a draw now we say should be I
mean really anything happens and
especially in bullet anything happens
but this should be I think that there's
good chances for David he's down on the
clock but that F5 Pawn is so weak and
the black king is misplaced so if David
can get some quick moves in here he goes
his King is coming up he's doing the F5
Pawn unbelievable
that is crazy that was definitely
supposed to be dropped but it was not I
mean you can't call anything you know
it's funny those King Rook versus King
roof and you still get flagged or you
still lose that kills you right there
but that's the thing about paravian he
is actually very quick and he knows how
to pre-move well that pawn is up there
he is trying to push it there it goes
he's gonna get a queen
rookie seven clinical
Ain't Gonna Make You Ain't Gonna mate
are you you're amazing it's close it's
close Kitty is he gonna do it
oh my goodness 0.2 seconds was the
Difference Maker and that's all you
needed he gets the win he is now up by
two points in that match and in the
other match between Jose Martinez and
Dennis luzvick uh we see that well it's
Jose who has the white pieces right now
and a one point lead so that match is
very very close
yeah that's a very close match there as
uh gonna be a lot of action now when I
think especially as they're going back
and forth is really about that win by
two two as well but here in this I mean
this heated matchup with David and Men
there I mean they are trading blows in a
way David is definitely up he's up two
games this is what you need but there is
a lot of games left do not underestimate
David I think Min is uh very well aware
of that
so true and paravian doing well in that
match and lazvik the underdog in his and
I'm looking at the left-hand side of our
screen here and we may even zoom in on
this matchup for a bit as we try to keep
track of both and oh looks like David
just blundered badly in the center
allowing Rook takes into D5 pieces are
falling for David but I see lazovic's
Knight is entrenched on D4 and his other
night is coming to join the party it
seems very nice for Las Vegas who's also
caught up in time yeah that's not gonna
be a good night with them Knights
looking like that these nights Izzy Carl
says they look very good but then look
at them moving both of them back
they were both on Diva or E6 now they're
on f8 and E6 like insane well it is just
sometimes we say this is just not real
like it's just not real you know
especially when you hit 30 seconds too
as well weird things happen very weird
things happen but whoa face takes let's
trade Queens Jose I think blundered
before he went for a night sacrifice but
there was no follow-up to it and now we
see the problem with it is that black is
simply up a knight the black king is a
little bit unsafe but doesn't look a6b2
thank you very much there's a queen oh
peace that's the queen that's me yeah
give me that too okay Knight somewhere
there it is push up
very fast very quick he said he's fast
but he's been a little too fast I feel
like because he's proving me so much
that he gave away most of his material
advantage
definitely gave it back and he's running
around as possible so four seconds oh
this anybody's game yes anyone's game oh
both sides trying to Queen but last week
gets there first
good pre-moves by Logic great job by him
and he takes that he ties the match up
oh that was so fast yeah that was so
funny the pawn got down there so fast
Robert I thought he was cheating
it was like crazy did you see the pawn
queen
knows how to get it done he also played
this exact setup against Fabiano
yesterday so Martinez he is a king's
Indian player as black and Fabi was
doing the same but look at these Knights
these holes in the position for uh
Martinez he's got to deal with it and he
just trades everything off hoping that
this liquidation helps his cause
depends on position obviously but I mean
black is pressing maybe the Knight is
kind of ugly on the rim there A4 MP6 a
little weak I like white knight of seven
yeah there we go and then what do we do
G4 okay Knight F6 and
he's just running around it seems the
light square is very pleasant for white
but E4 one of those moves that at least
gives black some activity and hope and
what's the material Suddenly It's white
who's up a pawn
G3 being active oh yeah this definitely
looks very nice for white open position
Bishops look good pieces are active this
is a recipe for disaster for the black
piece is here if we can convert Rook B7
is nice Knight F5 even better hold
everything Rook B7
yeah no your move is definitely coming
Rook B7 will hurt
oh yes yeah he went for like a one-off
little check look at the clock Dennis
Las Vegas is 10 plus seconds ahead
against Jasper we know how good and fast
Jose is maybe we're overlooking or
underestimating Dennis luzovich
[Laughter]
and he blunders a whole piece okay well
even 3150s blender pieces too they're
just human but what he's trying to do is
he's been trying to win on time and he's
playing a little bit too quickly in
blundering material and now he's
actually behind on the what's going on
what's wrong with Dennis they lose
connection goodness oh I think he's
Frozen look at him on camera he hasn't
moved I think he lost connection
I'll take the dub yeah give me that a
little shuffled a little shimmy there
whoa yeah that's tough that is the
internet Gambit as they call that one
Dennis went down to the internet Gambit
there and that is that sucks it really
does but it is part of online chess it's
a thing it does happen let's hope he
gets back very soon oh I think we've
seen him move but I felt like I was
watching Arnold Schwarzenegger in Batman
Mr Freeze like he just you're stuck in
place you can't do anything but now he
is back he's overcoming uh the ice has
melted and all that hopefully for Dennis
he's able to come back but you see this
the time he's down to 37 seconds because
he didn't have his connection and that
is part of the match all players know
that uh it's unfortunate but it's in the
regulations and they should be well
aware
yeah it's it's exactly it's in the
relegate it's part of it and that's
online chess for you you can be beating
Hikaru and about the Checkmate and
blunder your queen and lose the game
guess what you lose the game that's what
happens it's part of it it's the it's
the game that we play uh online chess
and they stay in checks right so tough
definitely tough there but uh now maybe
uh Jocelyn can use this to his Advance
use up a game here and it's only being
down one game anything yet a lot of
match left
and actually Dennis has played a really
nice game considering he started down
all that time he's trying to sacked in
exchange trying to go for the attack but
on the other matchup it seems like men
you see the way he's grabbing his head
he looks a little bit distressed whereas
David perovian is like okay I'm just
gonna look at the board keep doing my
thing oh two points and you know what
with that that's very nice for David I
think in a psychological standpoint too
as well and you know men hopefully he's
just just playing his game that's it and
getting over the fact that I think he
kind of knew that he was a favorite
going into this especially after having
a performance with Magnus I mean who
wouldn't feel like bro I I mean I was
beating Magnus like I only lost by three
games like I can do I can do anything
right and then you go in here and you're
down two games against David Arabian so
you are not actually you know like it's
not all sunshine and rainbows here it's
gonna be a lot of work B3
[Music]
that's a that's a fork it's a baby fork
with the B3 Pawn hitting both rook and
queen and now all of a sudden David is
up a lot of material but that black past
Pawn we know how dangerous these can be
in bullet games
definitely gotta be careful got to be
careful here it is still a lot of game
left my time is left of Eric 20 30
seconds 30 seconds a piece
plenty of time to make the most of this
Advantage for paravian and yeah it looks
like he's doing a really nice job of
converting it he's just trying to he's
giving up material that's actually a
very good lesson not just for bullet but
for all types of Chess when you're head
by a lot of material sometimes you give
some of it back to make your life easier
there you go lesson from Arbor Chow is
listen to the Robert Robert Hess lessons
I actually have one lesson from Robert I
never forgot to I even use it like
whoever controls the pawn breaks
controls the game I was like dang Robert
does oh and then never forgot it was
like years ago so you know Robert always
giving us the little lessons
bored I didn't mean to cut you off while
you're praising me you know it's 19 C4
right yeah you know what you know what
I've learned from you is you know G5 and
we live oh
G5
that's right and G4 for the score that
means guys push your Jeep on if you're
an aggressive player at some point in
the game you should have a problem
yes and well look at Men by the way he's
getting hit lower on the camera he's
grabbing his head in more frustration
David paravian up three points in that
matchup
oh yeah that's that's tough I mean like
if I'm man I am deaf I just have to get
over the fact that braven's very strong
play my game like just stop thinking
about that I was a favorite and all this
other stuff right I just had a play bro
and play better which is easier he's
just sitting down like a man just play
better like okay all right cool yeah
yeah let me try that let me try that bro
that's a good try I mean he's trading
off all his pieces he's the better end
game because the pawn structure and you
know what the biggest problem is James
is that you're supposed to be Coe
calculation over everything but you
don't have time to calculate a bullet
wow so we had to I mean you know we need
some weird stuff Chad you watching man
we need to get that's one of my mods he
works with our thumbnails in merch so
you know maybe we go ioe intuition over
everything when you're wearing blank
bullet right or you know speed soe
whatever you need to have more than
calculation in this bullet chest here
does this help to calculate you just
don't have the time to do it
and I'm looking at the boards here by
the way Dennis loveswick he is up a lot
of time and that bar is going all the
way down in his favor because he's about
to promote his past Pawn so laws make
down three points but it looks like he
is getting this one with a second Queen
appearing good on him and on the right
hand side of the screen it looks like
David paravian he's down a lot of time
Min is going for the the speed that's
what he wants right now but he's
dropping pawns on the queen side
definitely dropping those pawns there
and what is it looking like in the time
time is up a little bit a couple seconds
for men there men wants to convert this
but definitely not looking likely at all
there but we head shake probably gonna
end in the draw we always say that and
then something crazy happens made over
there on the other board who just won
that game uh Dennis one yes
okay
I feel like min's gonna flag him I
actually mentioned this a lot yesterday
when Anish was playing at zohanian you
have to be Shameless you just flag your
opponent when you're head on time and
Min has that experience playing against
Dania playing against the others you
just just move your Rook a bunch of
times don't fall oh he won
hit him split in but when anything
happens
you got it
his King just climbed the ladder up the
H file to G6 and there it's set to help
deliver a Checkmate so a win for Min and
now he's back in this match he's only
down by two points and oh looks like
Dennis loveswick he blundered something
because he is now down a piece against
Jose Martinez yeah that's tough I mean
being on a piece against anybody these
are these guys it could be over but of
course at any time yet you got too much
time to convert that boy
winning a lot of material get the
up
Aquila saying I've seen men come back
from far worse let's go yeah wow he's a
legend he's played so many online games
uh he's a popular streamer and right now
he's trying to come back in this game
with the black pieces and he is because
paravian just blooded horrible because
Rook Jade and Rook takes H2 with Knight
G4 to follow
oh that is gross that is nasty clean up
six Stakes yeah you can't even go queen
of sticks so he goes Knight A4 but that
he just takes it and like what in your
next move and your next trick buddy oh
okay hit the button yep he's gonna hit
the button there like we have six
rookies two take take Knight G4 and it's
there yikes that was nice
and I feel like with under 10 minutes
remaining on the match clock the players
are starting to go into the gamesmanship
uh territory of these matches where
they're like you know normally I resign
I'm completely lost I'm also uh you know
down a queen in some seconds but I have
to play this out because I want to waste
time off the match clock oh yeah for
sure I mean are you planning speeds up
here so yeah you're like no I need to
wake this clock out I'll wait you know
and just play it every single game out
until Checkmate especially when I'm up
and if you're up and you start to lose a
game or two you really want to keep that
lead as much as you can your opponent is
going to be coming at you because
they're down hopefully you're able to
react directly to that if you're up in
these games but whoa what the heck
happened in that game oh my goodness
mins are making mistakes and he's now
down on time and he's not even up
material if we do a quick count it's
Rook bishop and a couple pawns for a
queen so oh there was the bishop there
was the pawn there goes the neighborhood
roach man this is this is when I'm like
yeah bullet isn't real this just is not
real now of course time pressure makes
everything crazy happen but wow what are
their turn of events in that game that
was winning for men then suddenly it
wasn't winning and then he went full
Pac-Man and just ate everything in his
side so Min is now down by just one
point in the match meanwhile Jose
Martinez he looks to be pulling away
from Dennis loveswick on the left-hand
side of your screen he is up by three
points and he has an extra exchange and
he needs to deliver the knockout because
he is down it's just eight seconds on
the clock
oh man it was not made check he episode
The Way King H1 is he gonna take the
draw yeah ain't got no time he said take
the draw wow that's completely winning
but how I don't know you have to walk
yeah he could have he could have pushed
some Pawns in front of his King but when
you have no time you'd rather secure the
draw than flag trying to win and so now
we're back in the Min match against
David pravin under eight minutes of the
match clock this to my eyes looks like a
very Min position it's uh no clear
weaknesses for white whatsoever and he's
trying to improve his pieces one by one
and there's E4 gain a little bit of
space but it's it's out of nothing right
it's just you're not even getting an
advantage you're just playing for your
comfort zones
oh yeah of course playing for your
comfort zone is a very good place to be
you can play very fast when you're in
your comfort zone you're playing the
stuff you always play right this is
important to do trying to play stuff
that you're not as familiar with you can
get down on time which of course all the
time time is definitely a peas and
bullet it's like hey Robert's like yeah
it's like the fourth piece right after
the night in the bishop you know on
night Bishop clock
right okay very important in bullets
what is this what are you doing look at
pirate yeah
he's like James you're asking the right
questions what am I doing he can't
believe he's talking to himself and now
he's made it what is he doing
even match he's doing that thing will
you take a drink after you know you get
a good move or a good position so he has
quelched his thirst and for David
paravian yeah he's mad at himself he
threw that one very badly
absolutely and if I'm in here he stopped
trolling the hair that's how you know
all the pressure I'm good okay
hold on hold on let me throw a little
bit more so you know he working now he's
but he's like I'm back in the game I'm
back in again it was actually a two-game
match and now uh you very nice my man is
the men's back
he's backing for provin you know you
need to stay calm because your position
he goes H4 James he's playing your style
he is a player of your own heart oh 100
I love his aggression he actually plays
Greenfield too as well as I take a lot
of grenfield files just I was about to
say there's rookie seven that's exactly
I saw it I saw it Chad King H7 Queen F7
Rook ha Rook h11 oh H1 may I couldn't
even say it that was so hype I saw that
instantly and he played it I was so high
and they're both twirling their hair but
only Rook G7 Queen F6 things like that
look like they're in the air maybe it's
Rook G7 Rook H1 first but he goes
Bishops
bro
complete one first yeah because he had
that weird 97
but look at the clock it's paraben who
has a lead he's slowing down because
he's trying to find The Knockout that's
the wrong time to do it if he noticed
that he was up 10 seconds he could have
played quickly one time and now he's
frustrated with himself he's like come
on bro
come on man he's like defending like
yeah man is in four reason for him you
can't look at the defense wins
championships Rook A7 real hard Flex
stood up hard and it's not all the way
winning yet of course it still takes
some time oh tonight
oh gosh
men goes down there at Brook age seven
sick boy yeah it would have been sad for
him to spoil that move because that was
a sick one you spotted it real fast and
provin goes back up by one point and we
should remind everybody as we have that
it's a win by two format so as long as
mid doesn't lose another game even when
the time elapses he stays right in this
match because you have to have a
two-point margin oh yeah it's also four
four minutes left here wow spending time
there was so horrible says Greg shahadi
in the chat up Greg
right
you said it like I know you like Greg
but the way you said is almost like you
have some animosity you're like Greg
what's up Greg no thanks my guy I have
no animosity to him at all buddy he uh
he does that CrossFit thing yeah
and it looks like Jose Martinez he is up
by four points but Dennis loveswick he's
taking this game it's supposed to be a
three-point spread there so with four
minutes remaining that gives Dennis a
chance he needs to keep winning he
cannot stop winning but Jose is doing
the right thing by letting his clock run
out
yes in fact uh he's I mean he's up that
time I'm out of time but I'm up I'm up
the games which is very important if I
can just hold I mean do whatever here I
got we got three minutes to make up this
deficit of like three you know and you
actually need to well three games to try
it but then you need to have the
obviously to win by two there so really
yeah it's up to um to uh Dennis lives if
it can make it close make it a one game
match so we got more time to play it
and this match is very close one point
leading right now for paravian it
doesn't look like it's gonna be a one
point lead for long because look at Mid
he pushes past a pawn then steals all
the king side pawns and pravin's just
trying to move quickly he just has no
ideas in the position as it's completely
lost
he's coming he just got up out of there
I need to get the game going whatever oh
back to it
and Min goes back to that scandi we see
that he just puts these pawns out B7 and
C6 F7 and E6 he wants that solid
structure against the light Square
bishop and he keeps doing it and I feel
like Providence handled it very well
yeah this line is very aggressive I mean
like yeah this line is so nice for white
I don't know why he I mean this is the
I'm not even like this is like the most
aggressive line you can play for the
scandi with the queen side I mean the
pawn sack on D4 he pushing the pawns up
it looks like some type of Cecilia and
he didn't play C5 right so it looks
really really nice for white oh my God
I feel like David provin has to be one
of your favorite players just watching
him play this style of throw all his
pieces at his opponent and it's been
working out pretty well for him but
right now it looks like Min has
stabilized yeah the thing about men is
is defense is so good it's just like uh
you know like you know the uh the solid
game that he has actually translates a
lot into his defense as well he's very
nice with tactics obviously too his
defense bro yeah how did you defend that
like right now you know what just
happened and under this time pressure
too as well very incredible
I want to move King D6 was there bring
his King up the board he realizes okay
he may drop the A7 Pawn but it's even
material and if the white knight ever
takes the Black Knight that fixes
Black's Pawn structure and otherwise to
watch out for Rook H1 check night before
check and that's a force mate that's why
he Rook to B7 to stop night before and
the chat is actually talking about the
hero Terrell Championship I think it was
me and you commentating it too when they
had it was both twirly at the same time
it was like a hair twirl championship
there's a queen and whoa whoa what a
game you know what's funny about that is
black queen with check normally you're
the side who wins when you get that in
but White's King is safer blessed King
has to be checked me in a few moves yeah
you get made or queen bare minimum here
he made one you know six mate but this
game is he not one minute left
one minute
and we are gonna stay on this match
because Jose Martinez he's locked up his
he's up four points against Dennis
loveswick I think Dennis gonna cut it to
three but there's not enough time
remaining to get a couple more dubs and
whoa minute just stole a pawn in the
center of the board so David Gets a win
and then right away Min has an extra
Pawn in a good position
yeah right that's so annoying like all
right I gotta close it out probably not
this game but you know hey you know what
maybe let's uh yeah let's just stabilize
you know I'm up a game right then you
start thinking differently well you know
he's going to stabilize okay I got the
pawn back hopefully I'm okay
but look at how good these Bishops are
for white he's just Bishop 687 you take
on before this bishop C5 hitting both
Rooks at one so Min has a clear
Advantage an extra Pawn at the moment
and yeah this is gonna be Pawn push
Central for white this looks like a
clean one to be honest she's like are
you just gonna push them boys
going guys we got more chests in this
match yeah unless men blunder is like a
Checkmate out of nowhere even a draw
means the match continues but it looks
like he's well on his way to Victory
he's up a past Advanced Pawn all the way
there on B7
yeah it's an extra Pawn too as well the
one Pawn that I'm up is all the way down
they're restricting the pieces bro relax
really that's what you're doing bro
that's what you're doing huh
King I want I want yeah exactly King F1
King E2 Rook hitch one mate and rookies
yeah yeah
where's he
wait there could be a stalemate trick
like if you weren't careful there and
you like let those pawns to push or
something that black king was out of
real estate
no
oh my gosh
Min was up a piece completely winning
and that's the commentator's curse you
you know that's good I think it's good
analysis by us but maybe we curse them
in a little bit
that hurts man
oh man I'm so mad right I'll be so mad
that is crazy
what else is crazy what is this opening
black has a double e pods White's
pushing the pawn up on the a file this
is strange
yeah this is very strange here oh man 95
Rook E1
whoa
uh oh men cannot lose this game we're
officially in overtime right this is the
first of six games here and parabi is
just taking it to him
he definitely yeah he's trying to you
know hey if I can get away with that I
can get away with anything
he said so I think he's feeling a lot
better especially from what happened in
this game Queen E3 threatening Bishop C6
he said defending rookie eight Bishop G5
I mean we just have everything aimed at
you brother Mr G5 play there it is you
are correct min's a great defender but
as you shouting at that Rook D1 is great
just keep bringing pieces into the
attack there must be something here is
it
oh he doesn't find it it Flags back in
this
not sure what it was
and James a draw is perfectly acceptable
for men right you this is Win by two so
men if he gets a draw
366 simple
H5 okay B3 okay restrict H5 no G3 H5
okay nope don't play it now
it's going crazy today somebody's
stopping oh my gosh
and he's taking this match
letting Rook letting Rook
let him I love that that should be a
shirt you know normally you get to let
him cook but with a rook I love that
James and I don't think that men's loved
any partis paravian takes the match he
wins it by a score of nine to seven yeah
Greg should Hardy that was incredible
play by David he just took down one of
the goliaths of the online sphere this
game should not count the one that we're
seeing here is it's already game over so
they started a new game just out of
habit but paravian indeed moves on he
has won this match by two games
that's crazy I mean everybody around the
world except probably David Peruvian
fans was saying men is a favor I mean me
and clever man I'm a fan I'm a fan of
Ben also I'm a fan because of uh you
know how well he did against Magnus very
rare you ever see that Arabian today was
able to take down
that is incredible and he was so locked
in that he was ready to play that next
game like he probably in the back of us
I was like didn't I win this match it
doesn't matter I am just going to let my
moves do the work and they did David
paravian takes down minlay minlay who
took Magnus Carlson down to the wire
yesterday unfortunately his time in the
bullet Chess Championship has come to an
end we're huge fans of minlay great
streamer great player but David paravin
was up to the challenge as was Jose
Martinez they have identical scores nine
to seven as jospham and paravian move on
yeah he's more of a Dark Horse now now
they're now they're really paying
attention they like yo David David I
mean David like David question mark yeah
David right that's how it is right now
he has been taking down men there Jose
can have it be happy and smile as well
he won his match there but wow that was
epic definitely two good matches and
more to come Roberts that was
yeah for a second there you said all
those Davids I felt like I was listening
to Moira Rose and shit's creek that was
David David yeah David he's through he
has made it to the next round so as we
look at the updated bracket it is
paravian and Jose Martinez who make it
into the next round of the losers
bracket so as you see here in front of
you uh Nakamura versus naroditski
Carlson against farrugia that is coming
up next but we have etched a couple
names into losers bracket round three
paravian takes down minlay by a score of
9-7 Andrew Tang that was a one-sided
Affair against Eric Hanson 14-3 and Jose
Martinez he was able to get by Dennis
lazovic the teenager from Belarus gave
it his all but it wasn't quite enough
against the bullet brawl two-time
champion in Jose Martinez so this has
been fun already there is so much more
fun to be had but before we head to
break want to give a shout out to maybe
the most fun chess tournament of them
all because people love POG Champs and
yes POG Champs 5 is back it is coming
soon it is starting very shortly 16 of
the world's biggest creators will go
head to head in the greatest event in
amateur chess brought to you by
chess.com and pogchamps Legend Ludwig
watch your favorite creators like cutie
Cinderella Sea Dog VA xqc tyler1 I did a
thing and more fight for their share of
a 100 000 prize fund and a ticket to the
live finals yes live finals in Los
Angeles use the command POG and chat for
all the details and well it's going to
be an amazing podcast but first we are
going through the bullet Chess
Championship the winter semi-finals
begin right after this short break we'll
see in a few
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
becoming a chess streamer like your
favorite creators such as Hikaru Gotham
chess and the botan sisters come on look
at this
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Magnus takes it because it gets him the
match Wick tree what a match performance
this has been by the world number one oh
hello
wow Magnus Carlsen with the black pieces
Deliver Us Checkmate oh my God and we
have
rapid
who is the man in the mirror that is
Magnus Carlson and he has left the
building he can do that when he's the
number one player in the world he's
fresh off the aim chess rapid Victory
when he plays tournaments he often wins
but this is his first time in the bullet
Chess Championship so he's never won
that title James will it be his first
okay
oh did we lose James
we lost James but he might be back and
hopefully we get him ASAP but now it's a
just me sorry about that everybody I was
there just like you all like hey I want
to hear James Doss that's the person I'm
chatting with that's the person we all
want to hear from but we also want to
see Magnus Carlson take on Ali Rizza
faruja because that is the match that is
coming up that is the player that Magnus
said if he wins the candidates I will
square off with him for the world crown
that didn't happen Magnus abdicated the
throne but today we do see that Clash it
is Carlson it is farouza it is next and
following that we will have Hikaru
Nakamura taking on Daniel naroditski so
we have two of the best matches you
could possibly ask for in the Chess
World starting with Carlson and ferrugia
finishing the day with Nakamura and
neraditski I know you're not leaving I
know you're not going anywhere you are
getting your seat belts fastened because
we are in for some Epic bullet matches
and these matches actually have 45
minutes per side that's what happens in
the winter semi-finals and onwards in
the winners bracket it's 45 minutes that
lessens the variance it gives players
more time and it still is Win by two so
a rough start doesn't mean the end of
the road for the players they will still
have a chance to fight on and speaking
of fighting on it seems like James Canty
has done just that he has fought through
a little bit of rough connection and
he's back with me what's up partner
yeah man it was the internet Gambit it
was the same thing that got hit with uh
you know um a Dennis lives if you had a
little internet Gambit sometimes it just
blips you know it happens and just weird
things happen sometimes with these
computers these days but we are back and
we are ready to see Magnus go at it here
with Ali Reza farusha guys how is the
chat feeling this you I need some energy
I want to see the chat absolutely go
crazy right now because this is about to
be a crazy legendary match right now
and I want to see everyone in chat well
I won't see it because you know I'm not
looking but I want you all to let us
know who you think is going to win will
it be Magnus will it be alireza and this
is the match that we are about to
witness so it seems like they're over 5
million Channel points gambled by chat
on the predictions 60 of you said that
Magnus will take down alireza and when
Magnus is playing usually it's more than
60 but there's nothing guaranteed in a
matchup against farugia here in the
winner sami's James I'm gonna put you on
the spot I know your internet Gambit
just happened but I'm gonna have to ask
you will it be Magnus or will it be Ali
Reza going through the winners final
I'm going with big mag with the mag
that's my guy of course but I do like
farrugia as well farouza is very strong
attacking player I love looking at his
games but definitely like Magnus uh a
lot he also shouted me out to my family
to stream it so I'm like oh Magnus
what's up dog and I was like fire and
actually I saw him in Dubai chatted with
him for a little bit so you know Magnus
is uh it's cool right obviously I would
do want to go with Magnus here but I
think I I just love I'm excited to see
the chess overall because of what these
guys bring to the table both over 2800
in classic chess so you know it's very
good to see them just clash and
hopefully they can even play I mean you
don't study bullet games but these you
may be able to in fact of course of some
of them it may be a Roy Lopez down to
move 40 Theory you know what I'm saying
stuff like that happens with these guys
so it is a fight
and I thought you were going to say that
farooza will bruise you because I really
thought that you were gonna pick the
upset special with first and actually is
it really an upset like these two
players feel so evenly matched in bullet
chess they both have uh up there with
the highest ratings along with Hikaru
and Dania and Andrew Tang when Andrew's
in his best form so I feel like we can't
even really call it an upset in fact if
we ask Magnus I wonder if he thinks that
Fraser might even be a slight favorite
yeah I think you know he knows I mean
they play so many games together and
like you know even he said for the world
championship he was like yo you know I
I'm not really interested unless for
Rouge they are they are like so he
really respects Perugia here so I think
Magnus Magnus is going to take it
serious and when he takes stuff serious
that's that's a scary thing because then
Magnus bringing out that extra level
that makes him number one for so long
right so I'm like I'm excited to see
that and fruition wants to challenge
that he's like yeah I mean I know you
number one you know I beat you before
let's uh let's see if I ain't gonna win
this bullet match but
and here we go so you don't have to wait
any longer that people were waiting for
Magnus versus alireza now they get it it
is game one Magnus with the white pieces
he adopts a pretty solid setup so far
nothing too major has happened but that
D4 Square black and sink a night in
there that could be good news
I just learned something so quick
already I mean you know I'm a kid
specialist and I love King's Indian I
just won he's a strong I am in my last
tournament okay ID for life right is
what we say but what he did was he moved
his knight from f8 around the E6 very
quickly you got the Knight over to H7 so
it was
weekly
this is holding everything it's a game
of night Maneuvers that night went from
E6 to C7 and it's up to B5 now so it
can't stop won't stop the night
continues it's tour of this board and
now the white Knight's turn to improve
itself
lots of maneuvering G4 Knight F3 Bishop
G4 there oh great on that F3 so I feel
like black is doing quite nicely look at
this activity for the pieces oh G5 fell
up but was that a blunder or a sacrifice
yeah because he didn't move instantly I
think it was a blunder but I mean he did
find something out of that he's still
doing oh my goodness Kingston here for
the win we don't ever have to play
another opening King's Indian for the
win once again can we get some kid in a
chat King's Indian defense I'm always a
special
who likes King's Indian defense this
one's a wrap that's that Queen is
trapped let's go up to E2 then you force
the Queens off and you win the ensuing
endgame Magnus resigns he doesn't want
to test alirez's mouth speed he knows
that it would be over so Ali Reza faruja
is the first player on the scoreboard he
gets up one to nothing and now in game
two Magnus he's given up a pawn will he
get it back
uh his question here is Willie in it uh
okay
I do like wise position here the space I
mean it's this Advantage you got to
clean the E3 everything's defended then
he attacks on again castles like hey G4
hey
you know what that night on E7 is that
really a night that doesn't look like
the pony that kids dream about that
Knight can't go anywhere oh but those
pawns are all dropping off
it takes yeah they now it can get out to
Magnus here in G5 takes uh yep Agnes is
back
I think he's gonna let this one slip but
if you take this bishop on C3 then white
takes the Knight on E7 and then there's
Nike G5 ideas that King is in trouble
and now B7 is gone that gives way to
pass my goodness bro
it's about to be a 2-0 frozen relax you
know this Magnus right like you know
this is Magnus I mean I don't know if
you know that I like this Magnet or else
it's maybe he's winning now there it is
yeah okay he's like yeah he was lying uh
you get this one it's two nothing and
another reminder that we are 45 minutes
of bullet chess in the matches in the
winners semi-finals and Beyond in the
winners bracket so uh this gives Magnus
more time even if he loses this game he
has a little bit more time to catch up
sometimes James people need to find
their Rhythm they just can't find their
form from the start
that's right it does take some time
there we do have actually MBL in the gym
he's going for
for the um
or Ali Reza's there I think you can
probably see four interesting yeah
what's Happening Here looks like The
Rook just has to back up and the A6 Pawn
that is going to be a long-term Target
so Magnus is trying to coordinate his
pieces and shout out to mvl one of the
best chess players in history a former
World Blitz Champion uh he's had so many
successes to his name but he's rooting
for his compatriot that other is a
furious plays for friends and Bam Bishop
H2 check will follow if the Knight were
to move so Ali Rizza just won a piece
he's probably thanking his friend Maxime
for stopping by
got a little freeze there
and we're back
hey what happened actually uh internet I
think we're good
you're good James I think we're good I
think we're good here what happened in
this last game here oh Ali resident bro
what no that yeah it's two to one right
no no no no Ali Reza won again he
doesn't stop winning that's what's
happening wait is this really 3-0 it's
3-0 it is no that's not a typo that's
not a typo
Robert let me ask you again Robert is
this typo or like I mean my internet
went out a little bit
it you know it's not a typo
Magnus has not won a game in the first
three he's trying to win this fourth one
ah yeah you crazy
I don't believe it I don't believe it I
gotta go back and watch the vibe oh oh
what Magnus allows E7 the past Pawn can
go up but otherwise it doesn't play at
first and now the e-pawn is it's gone
it's just drop what is this okay he okay
so if he's back in the game I was just
kind of Silent here because I was just
looking at like bro Magnus how three
games what if you lose another one then
I'm like I'm gonna be over here sweating
like I'm playing like literally oh yeah
that's just nice yeah he's winning now
Magnus
yeah his Bishop's protected by the rook
and so now he is up one Pawn but very
importantly the white king is in danger
and the H2 Pawn That's essential you
need to keep that one and black has
gained a passer
hey
whoa push push oh we can win this is
just over it's over just hit the button
resign there and respect right but let
me keep playing it lay it out yeah he
resigned now whatever the clock by the
way Magnus finished that game of 15
seconds like he played fast he played
well and he put pressure on farooza both
on the board and on the clock
I am uh very impressed I mean I think
everyone is right now I think everyone I
think everybody's on the edge with their
seats seeing farrugia Oh three oh whoa
hey man hold on bro this is like that's
supposed to be cool this is definitely
was um was crazy I mean to see I'm
excited to see the rest of this
obviously 23 maybe five take take this
off Theory H3 yeah yeah
but this is the type of theater that I
know puts you to sleep you're like come
on we're the tactinos
exactly for breakfast lunch and dinner
and this was none of those in this game
but of course I could have tried B6 C6
just to keep the pawn as a wedge there
but it might be weak after C5 whatever
for the game right but still uh
very theoretical review
oh my goodness he wants to trade because
E4 is now loose and it's grabbed and
that's an extra Pawn for farugia
all the works takes takes is this not
Knight C4 F3 Knight F6 takes takes d5's
hanging E6 is hanging they both hang in
there it might be drawn you know he can
definitely draw these type of positions
but bullet changes everything up it does
I'm looking at the clock so of course we
see the eval bar suggesting that faruga
is better but I'm looking at the time
and Magnus up a couple seconds so he's
gonna use that to his Advantage you
can't afford a nitrate that's why he
drops his Knight back so we're just
doing this perfectly just go after white
spawns and get a bit more active
look at that Magnus getting Magnus you
know what I mean like when do you ever
see that Magnus getting Magnus in the
end game right now they still chances
for a draw Still chances very difficult
yeah you know what you're just gonna do
just move that's all you have to do if
your max look at the clock I don't think
alvareza has enough time to convert this
advantage
this is a moment of silence
like I gotta see if he's gonna convert
this oh man check move okay yeah yeah
Knight G4 doing good
he's almost there Magnus paused which
was probably not a good thing to do
there at that moment oh now farooza has
it he's meeting oh my goodness this guy
is unreal peruses relaxed and Magnus is
frustrated you could see it on his face
that deep sigh of just like what do I
have to do to survive against this
youngster but farouza he's determined
you know he wants to win
yeah he's uh I mean he's he is ready to
be Magnus here in front of everyone he's
trying to now obviously Magnus it's it's
a lot of time left 36 minutes but
alireza is up three games right now and
he's in great form very hot we're gonna
see what happens here wow this is crazy
to see okay so Focus takes takes Rook D1
27 everything equalish yeah opposite
colored Bishops but White Queen is
that's annoying to the black pawns on
the queen side so everything protected
in the position for both players I don't
see a single weakness and now the pieces
are coming off so as you said equalish
is probably leading towards Josh
yeah
bullet changes everything too like that
one mistake in the end game on move 46
when you should have went King E6
instead of King D6 now you zugged out
you have a rescue page 820 right you
actually like then you lose in a bullet
game like it's crazy the high level
bullet
and I mean we agree with that by a ninja
26 this should be broadcast on every
existing screen in the world uh yeah
this is two of the best players of all
time to the best players currently who
are now going to try to flag each other
they'll probably just make a repetition
in a bishop of opposite color ending so
the draw has happened repetition and
that means that ferrugia keeps his
three-game lead how is Magnus going to
take all the reason down that is what we
need to see before we can believe in
magnus's chances
oh yeah that's right yeah we're gonna
see a lot of oh D5 whoa that is not
familiar with that
there was some recent Theory with this
oh yeah it was Jordan Jordan right
Jordan van for us it's like so
interesting stuff
experience C1 on Bishop C2 or Bishop T5
E4 doesn't care about any of that yeah
white has the center but black is the
bishop pair and you mentioned Air Jordan
who's been a second for Magnus before
and look at these pawns what is
happening in the center of the board
Rook takes E5 there's G4 blocking the
PIN
oh that's nice I could have taken I have
three first queen F3 hits F7 so he takes
now he goes for it anyway oh Rook D5
yeah oh my goodness so many tactics yeah
but white has to be better here look at
this you're going on the attack on the
offensive Rook C6 comes to mind and it's
played
and now it's a pass Pawn D7
yeah he's feeling good there we go
Magnus back yeah back there
that's a dub because the black king can
reach E7 but there's Knight C6 check at
the end and we're seeing something like
it uh I think otherwise will just resign
in a couple moves or maybe uh there is
the resonation maybe he's thinking about
match strategy let's play these out it's
too early in the match or so 34 minutes
remaining but you know in the back of
his head he's like all right I have the
lead maybe I should burn some of the
clock
all right maybe he's a Bryson clock here
and then we have a French man another
friendship Magnus was playing a lot of
this lately actually
Frenchies
I hate giving out that light Square
Bishop but that is Theory I like going
more Bishop D3 to keep it and queen E2
here same position but you still have a
bishop here I'm with you everything I
love that light score Bishop in the
French but uh it looks like Ali razor
says I'm just gonna lead in development
but Magnus has found a way to Castle so
he has the bishop pair and if you get E5
next followed by Bishop E6 and suddenly
we're talking about an advantage for
black with open space
that's what he did does as well he goes
back to C3 instead of Queen D5 check
allowing Bishop E6 you can see three
take take Bishop F5 and this is a fine
French it's kind of annoying when you
get the French like this black
definitely has some nice chances himself
he might have G4
over there
uh Brooks it was Queens bring something
to C4 bring your Rooks in the game and I
guess white has a pawn advantage on the
queen side three on two but black has
such a nice Central Pawn in E5 and I
don't see how white makes any initial
progress
very difficult to do that oh that's a
nice night on D5
but it's only a good night it just looks
great yeah episode six sounds beautiful
D4 man look at the this is the Magnus
work Magnus working there pieces on the
greatest squares King on F5 can't really
do anything nothing runs in at some
point F6 is defended this was a clinical
way to do it here it comes King E4 King
F3 and that should be that okay F5 is a
nice move to include But Here Comes the
black king F4 check he load F4 check
oh my goodness anymore
he hated you can see it in his face he's
losing what is this bro this doesn't
make any sense takes takes this bullet
chest look at the clock speaking of bull
chest Magnus is ahead on time so he's
losing by position because he was doing
all that funny business but he's
actually oh is he ahead not for long now
he's behind
four seconds here remove Primo pre-move
everything's pre-moved he's going oh
oh you know this Rook what is gonna
happen oh he Flags he hits the table he
smiles oh this is about to get serious
oh man he mad now he mad now my goodness
it's about to get crazy that would
ferrugia gave away his Rook because he
was essentially pre-moving Magnus took
the Rook but didn't have enough time
remaining to steal the last few pawns
and secure a draw so farouja gets
another Win Mag slams the table he gives
a smile though because I think he
appreciates it right you know he's like
all right respect Young fella
yeah yeah he's definitely mad and it is
respect because he said you know even
the world championship like hey look I'm
not interested unless from playing
farrugia here so he always has this
because you know I mean everybody is
challenged there but man
Roger is up you know three games on
Magnus like it's nothing if Magnus
malding oh man this is crazy this I've
never seen this
never seen this I don't think Chad has
either Magnus is simply down upon right
now but F5 is a good move the black king
cannot enter back on the E file there'll
be rookie one check with a skewer so
White's trying to push the pawn go king
of four and look at the clock that
otherwise is burned suddenly Magnus is
up like eight seconds and now the
advantage is also heading back towards
his Direction
yeah it's looking good here takes takes
I mean he's getting the right positions
what's the time okay so he's up 10
seconds oh how is that losing you
kidding me what great move by foreign
I thought it was White's move I thought
there was like a pre-move but as Black's
turn after Rook h8 so both sides are
just queened wait what's happening Brook
C8 and take on C4
what happened oh he's back in the game
oh man bullet is unreal I don't know I'm
not over here sweating like I'm playing
like this is wow this is so crazy to see
okay b6z I'll take yeah yeah let's go to
the a file so what magazine do is
pre-move like non-stop he should go King
A2 he he went Pac-Man but he could have
won King A2 King A1 and so on but that
was crazy James because faruga was
completely winning and then Magnus you
know he just took all the tricks out of
his bag and he he saved one
right he saved one there he definitely
got away I would breathe a little bit
all right who I can breathe because that
was gonna be four points when you get
four not only are you mad but you're
down four points and you're mad you know
that's different that is a different
feel and time is running out I remember
looking at the clock and it said 45
minutes at some point right with 29
minutes guys right I mean we love seeing
these games but the time is eventually
going to run out and someone is going to
be a winner here today right now
Borussia up games on Magnum regain
insane see what happens
Knight E6 he goes really sad man but it
feels like White's King has no shelter
definitely think so C4 takes on okay
because Queen C6 oh yeah played anyway
F3 yep
or you have no pieces he did too much
there yep two minor pieces for a rook
and black has well a very safe King and
now the initiative with all these pieces
coming forward so Magnus he needs this
game he's also up 15 plus seconds
that's yes let's go over yeah you can
just resign now this is always the
starting of the game you gotta Crush
that game in fact Magnus he has a mad
Magnus that was a dominating game here
five yeah
and this opening Scandinavian it worked
out for Magnus playing some offbeat
stuff trying to you know keep others out
of his comfort zones but suddenly it
feels like all these back in the game
except for the fact that he's so far
down on the clock
eight seconds here and then we will
probably we could see a flag on the
other end
so Rook B1 he has a couple checks
him uh he takes this Rook that was a
very smart move Bishop to B4
doesn't work yeah you don't know what's
gonna happen you see this Evo bar going
nuts here okay F5 Bishop back up we got
material V2 is hanging not anymore check
Kings we check again wait what happened
to them he's pre-moving Magnus is trying
to play very quickly and that's why he's
giving away pieces but we do see that
magnet oh my gosh he's moving too slowly
he takes the queen but he's got a little
time oh
he loses on time
oh did he lose wrong time bro he did and
you could tell he took one from Taylor
Swift he's trying to shake it off but
farouja says I don't care how I get the
dub as long as I keep on winning
yo my hand might be going through the
computer if I'm like here I guess the
whole arm might go through the computer
there wow he whacked him again
I wonder how the internet connection is
out there in Barcelona the hotel that
the chess bras and Magnus are staying at
you know that doesn't seem to be what's
deciding these games but at any moment
you know you need to make sure what
wait wasn't Rook takes D4 a free piece
I thought it was it was wait there was
yeah that was just free yes it's free
that's for me all right before it was
definitely moved oh man you can see he's
over here in yeah yeah using the words
whatever that is that's definitely
probably some adult language
wow I'm missing what he said over here
but it is definitely not looking good
right now for me he's just man Arusha is
working unbelievable here I really
thought Magnus had the upper hand I'm
gonna lie but I think everyone did
but uh wow got some work to do if he's
gonna come back so what I asked is
ferrugia even the underdog I actually
didn't think so and he's proving that he
can hang with mags and not just hang
with him he has a big lead and right now
Magnus may be up about eight seconds but
for us up a pawn so I don't know how to
weigh that trade off
yeah oh that was nice before their taste
takes
wow yeah you gotta draw this okay you
know what let's stop saying that these
games don't UBS to draw and then they
flag it's this is anybody's game even
white can win this believe it or not but
the clock situation is you know it's
getting closer to level that's good news
for farouza who's up a pawn and I think
he wants to win this game he's looking
at Magnus and saying you're not quick
enough to hang with me
wow wow them words would never come out
of my mouth like I mean unbelievable you
know but right now it is working in
farooza's favorite he had two games by
flag and again it doesn't matter how you
get it it matters did you get it done
right so he does oh wait he he moved and
he may not be getting it done here baby
boy and let's see let's see the speed
from from Magnus he's not putting the
king in check at all he needs to put
that King exactly
21.1.1.1 oh and Perugia left his yeah
do you think he threw his Mouse where
did he go he probably did
he might have thrown the mouse off
Instinct and like oh my bad I forgot let
me uh Reach In The Box for the next
Mouse because I got a box of mice next
to me because I break a lot of them 0.1
wow and for once Magnus steals a victory
I mean that one was ever so close 0.1
seconds left that is all you need to win
a game on time and now we're back to a
three-point deficit and if we look at
this game here it looks like Magnus with
the black pieces has control the open
file he also has a 10 second lead in the
clock so Magnus James he's been jumping
out to the early leads in these games
but then first just speeds up and that's
where he does his damage
and the problem is you know farooza is
not only speeding up but he's playing
Super tricky some stuff is very accurate
and you get these attacks and these
tactics out of nowhere because you know
he's a tactical absolute wizard with
this stuff Perugia is of course
and Magnus can spot tactics too as well
but even in magnus's style he doesn't
care as much for the opening advantages
he likes to grind it's a slow chest he
can do anything Universal player oh
whatever reason with these tricks man
and the time before it takes takes
that's clinical so magnets could have
traded pieces and said I don't want to
trade pieces look at the pawn structure
double isos on f file and default and
The Rook just fell in the corner so now
black is up at full piece with a safer
King bring your knight into the attack
there it is over queen of Fate watching
oh my God oh my God
he shook his hands out let me shake it
off let me stretch and flex real quick
y'all forgot my name's mac oh my
goodness farooza did the worst thing
imaginable he took that Rook which was
smart but Magnus saw that coming he's if
I take your Rook I get checkmated when
that pod promotes he ran his King away
and farouza was pre-moving you can't
pre-move that early I think he himself
would tell you that if you asked him
advice on how to improve as a bullet
player you can't pre-move that early
because when you get hit with an
unexpected move you're the one who's
gonna be in trouble and well we're
looking at trouble for Magnus he just
won a couple games but now he's just a
terrible position from the white side
this is pretty gross but he did
definitely win back and now he's feeling
good I mean I feel hey got some games in
it's a two-game match I make it a one
game match we can play this forever of
course we don't allow that here with the
format but we would like to see it and
you know people have took off work for
this let's go Rook C3 work G3 does have
some type of attack head shake there
from farrugia because look at that Rook
H3 he doesn't want a black Rook to help
in the defense and E3 just like a calm
little move saying you're not going to
take any to a check now the black king
is hunted Queen G7 Queen takes F7 uh
there's probably other things oh Bishop
C6 doesn't even go for the check just
yet
wow because he wants queen D5 after all
that E7 Queen F7 he he blundered in a
lot of Queen trade
jeez
oh no all his pieces are gone and he's
mad he's very very mad I think he's
trying to convince himself that he can
do this by shaking out all those
blunders
shake it out you know what that's that's
what we're doing check out the bar all
right cool let me shake shoot a lot of
y'all need the hyperventilate shape so
let's get the shakes out if we shaking
the blunders out that's what we're doing
perfect perfect shake it off chat
and get off take the blunders out all
right that's the new thing the new thing
yeah you know what
there's uh the Harlem Shake and then
there's the Magnus shake and
you know then there's the chocolate
shake that I want to drink so you know
either either way we look at it it looks
like Magnus he's playing a good game
here Rook D2 his B2 hits F2 and Bishop
A6 is gonna hurt at some point as well
or Rook is on C2 he's bringing a lot of
Rooks to the seventh here should be six
very strong
A4 wants A5 looks like maybe Rook to B1
takes on C6 so d8 is hanging Magnus with
a head shape there he's got a lot of
that man from both sides too but man
he's just really frustrating Magnus
it's understandable
so
A4 is on a light Square C4 is on a light
Square that's good news when they have a
light Square bishop and down goes the
pawn version decides the sacrifices to
give Magnus double pawns but this is
looking good for black at the stage and
I'm looking at the clock again maggots
is the faster player out of the gates
but then ferrugia he gets into that next
gear at some point
yeah I think he started getting into
that next year after he figures out the
opening that's what I'm saying he's like
oh this will be doing all right cool
then you just start speeding which is
causing some of his demise as well when
it comes to like that pre-move game
where you sacked the queen it was
brilliant and then you lost immediately
afterwards with the free move so here we
go
that the mouse might be too small for
him and causing him some pain so if we
do get an interview with Magnus we'll
have to hear about it he does actually
seem physically paint
that actually does seem correct 100 and
it is important guys to grab the right
Mouse and I'm sure he knows that I mean
he's not his first time you know he even
streams too as well but we do need to
get him something probably better uh for
that I think he does have some wrist
problems with that it wasn't shaking but
then with the constant of it and it's
matched that can affect
and I like this comment bullet chess is
a dance competition for the eval bar
yeah that thing's going up and down it's
a workout all right stockfish no they
don't get enough and they're not enough
challenges here so bullet chess I will
do that and H4 just dropped Knight comes
into G5 I see the eval bar saying
White's on like slightly better I would
initially think this is completely
winning and Magnus is also up 10 seconds
oh yeah and then
having a right Mouse is very important
guys of course I think some of the
flagging was due to the Mouse and his
hand actually cramping properly with the
mouse that he's using you do have to
actually see what's about that if we get
interviewed with him but yeah something
to definitely think about as we see the
handshake after like every game now and
I'm looking at the clock and every game
it does seem like Magnus is well ahead
and right now he is up nine seconds so
this is where all the reason needs to be
careful you can't just pre-move certain
decisions and Magnus is going for the
win he is decided to spring for your
pass Pawn
oh
yeah over G7 but he has to stop the same
Pawn first that's smart very strong very
strong that's sick even dude you have to
sacrifice try to win the a pawn
and what or Mr Dixie five and he goes B3
what a move an A3 Magnus wants to win he
wants to flag the guy
A3 Magnus seven seconds great move
Bishop B5 that is GG that's BG and
diagonal method after that push check
anyone to see Pawn he won
what a game see that's what happens when
you have a lead on the clock you can
take certain risks you can make some
decisions that may not be objectively
the best but in terms of Chess play but
they're objectively best in bullet and
Magnus gets the dub alireza he sees that
his leads shrink to two he's still doing
really well playing great bullet but
James I think we have to say that Magnus
must be feeling good about the
conclusion of that game
Man actually you know what I'm looking
at the feature chat Mouse is the 19th
piece right so we talk about the clock
and then you need a mouse right so like
it's different that's just so funny
extra piece there whoa what happened
what the hey bro what likes whoa whoa we
was just whoa yeah he's in pain yeah it
really is and I think he's in pain
because he just got his King slammed off
the board with Knight takes E7 and a
fork so uh that's the problem that
Magnus had right now he gets a couple
wins and then he has like a really bad
loss in there and it's credit to alireza
for just taking it to him all the reason
knows he's gonna lose some games you're
playing Magnus Carlson you're playing
bullet chess but I think he recovers
very nicely
yeah absolutely recovery and that comes
with obviously 100 youth having as many
games I mean as Magnus probably would
like still as well the youth part um so
it's just very rich you're still playing
very quickly very fast stuff like that
as well but yeah this is tough magnets
with a headshake again there yeah
something with the mouse a little bit of
pain I think if he had a better Mouse
and wasn't in pain you probably would
cease a better Magnus here too as well
this is amazing that is amazing black is
up a pawn and your coaches tell you
trade while you're ahead he goes to the
end game and he's losing because the A5
Pawn is on a dark square and White's
gonna Bishop E5 Bishop takes D4 Bishop
F2 same idea take on D4 then win the C3
Pawn then win the A5 Pawn it's that
simple
how crazy is that right when they do
tell you trade when you're up not when
you're down you trade when you're up and
you lose and you like you know what I'm
not ever doing that again right somehow
he is able to run his King over but I
mean practically it still looks very
good for white with the two passes I
think what happened was that Bishop was
a little bit too close to the black king
saving a vital Tempo and the White Queen
side pawns haven't moved quickly enough
but as you said this is bullet and when
it talking about an end game like this
that still gives white good chances to
win because the black pass pawns are not
even pawns anymore they're off the board
yeah this is wait a second I mean wait
um
but maybe not B7 Knight takes B7 then A7
that was a oh gross that's it
and a queen and they're back to one game
but you see Magnus again I mean he is
just like in pain he's shaking off his
hand there it doesn't matter if he wins
or loses so it's clearly not a results
based action and well you know I hope he
doesn't get arthritis and carpal tunnel
from playing this match
yeah one match right yeah especially all
the energy there but no we just do we do
it wish him the best it's not uh it's
not fun to play in pain and anything in
fact so it is important that you have
the right ergonomics and the right
settings and setups for long matches
like this which usually has a shaking in
the middle of the game you know what I
mean so this is definitely affecting
this play I think
um so it's important at home guys to get
the right stuff I actually just bought
uh I see some minor chat says razor I
just bought razor yesterday in fact from
Best Buy this is like yo you just get
you know the right stuff when you're
playing these online games guys it's
important well Max has the right stuff
and he wants to win because the winner
of this match is guaranteed 12
000 so a lot at stake while the loser
goes down to the losers quarterfinals uh
these guys are good they should play
professionally yeah that's true I think
that would be good advice for them and
right now Magnus with the black side of
this position he's up in exchange he's
trying to trade while ahead but in his
own terms not like last game with frugia
unfortunately stumbled into to a bad end
game
absolutely here as uh we're moving a
little bit but I may have the exchange
practically I'm just winning practically
so I have to work it as he's doing make
sure I improve my position by moving
pieces and pawns ahead which he's doing
he's doing that
what do you say mouse over everything
okay I like that I like you we about to
get some merch with that Mouse over
everything okay I think Magnus just you
know he wiped that dirt off his
shoulders there like he's like all right
now it's tied match and Magnus is
actually playing more quickly than Ali
Reza is Right we've seen Max up on time
quite a bit he's lost some of those time
scrambles except when he'd point one
seconds remaining so here it's important
for alireza he needs to settle down and
uh oh wait why did that bar go so high
he went really high there after age six
maybe F or something
interesting there's some like H4 G6
Queen H5 stuff it's range yes it's
impossible to figure out with no time
and you're just gonna make these quick
moves at the early stage and give me
that D5 Square says Magnus I'm gonna
plop my pieces down and well if you take
on D5 that's a pass Pawn in the center
fix takes and he holds it holds the five
Pawn Rick probably swinging the D1 at
some point plays A4 break the structure
down
and I think we're gonna see at some
point Rook D1 Pawn G4 White's Just Gonna
Keep black tied down to the Past Pawn
but I don't think that it's a big
concern so this is good news for oh
there is a the bishop blockades the pawn
The Queen Is Now free to run and running
it it does it goes down to A2 and maybe
into C2
and Rook C2 is going to be quite
annoying that is going to be a very
annoying move we're C2 anyway paper C3
first and they send me to Ava that
allows
I guess he could have played that anyway
s
he does play Queen two F5 is loose I
didn't even realize that I was trying to
trade Queens in an earlier variation but
stealing a pawn don't blunder Checkmate
and oh again he trades when he's ahead
like his coaches always tell him and
somehow that was a bad oh there's was a
rook at fate in Bishop C5 I guess not
yeah not anymore here he's worth walking
the King right he's winning F5 is going
to come with a check before F5 check
take take and we push yeah and we push
walk the dogs in the park very easy push
push push push
and push and that's that Magnus he
throws in the towel he's down five
seconds and a couple pawns I mean he
really is in pain right now like you
could see it yeah on his face I think
some people they try to make that excuse
right they're like they're ready if they
lose the match oh something happened but
he's doing it no matter what's happening
on the board and as somebody you know
who does struggle with wrist issues when
you don't have a good Mouse and you're
trying to play speed chess it can really
hurt
oh yeah he'll never have that again and
I think it is this mouse at least or at
least the setup to do that it is
important to have the right Mouse the
right table setting right uh everything
here obviously a mad is good ergonomic
keyboard this is important if you want
to have very long longevity in obviously
uh the online space so it's very good to
do that but Know It's just tough love to
see because we know he's in pain right
now
but I think that he's in pain both
physically and on the board in this
position because White's Advantage is
through the roof I think at some point
F5 is going to hurt like just throw your
Pawn forward play in the candy style
that we love right and go for there it
is go for checkmate there it is you know
it's funny you said somebody in the chat
says chess is a dangerous sport bro like
sue you know
this is dangerous man them pawns you
know those kings that hurt you bro you
gotta be careful so it's uh that's a
funny one here but it is important to
definitely work on your game and also
your ergonomics you can play for a long
time nice sacrifice we got an aggressive
position here
E6 there it is
that is maybe the move of the day if you
take with the Knight F7 Falls if you
took with a bishop there's a Checkmate
on d8 so he was rookie seven but now
this bishop is pinned and that's amazing
here as well it's my first arrows of the
day that's how good the move was
Brazilian
oh yeah
I love tactics and he does a lot of
those I mean he you know we've seen him
do when he used to stream we would see
him do puzzles and just blow through
puzzles nice to do your puzzle
and now it's under 10 minutes remaining
so Magnus he needs to catch up it is Win
by two this has been very important in
certain matches like in the one between
Jose Martinez and a niche that was the
end of the first day of action but if
Magnuson keep this deficit to one you do
get extra time nine plus minutes
remaining James hit the white pieces
here for Magnus do you believe in his
chances I do believe in his chances here
I do believe uh I mean he's very clutch
Under Pressure he's done this many times
he is playing some very strong
opposition of two games right now but
you know if we don't see it happen in
the next three minutes it's not gonna
happen it's not gonna happen so he does
have time maybe two or three more games
to get this thing really going here
um but you know it's difficult I think
he can do it
yeah so we'll see what it is Mike he
gets in this game he's down a pawn but
he has the pair of Bishops that Rook on
Eight's been hanging for a little bit
but some trades occurred first and well
alireza he's really handling himself
perfectly in this match he's playing
well in critical moments he's keeping
Pace when it seems like he's down a
bunch of time and right now he's down a
few seconds but he's catching up
and here we see that the pieces are
coming off the board Black's still up a
pawn and well it's an extra Pawn on the
a file that's always good news but white
has the bishop and white has the lead on
time so 10 seconds Advantage for Magnus
as he pushes his H Pawn I think he just
done that well today giving away a pawn
to double his opponent's Pawn structure
and after H5 Falls maybe H6 is next so
this position looks really good for Max
don't put a Checkmate the king went back
so it avoided that and the king is gonna
go back to G2 A7 Falls King for black
needs to come up the board he only has
nine seconds he needs to gobble those
pawns but as long as Magnus has a rook
he should try to flag his opponent no
draw offers this no don't play that move
do not trade Rooks when your opponent is
five seconds that is probably one of the
earliest rules you learn as a top bullet
player Magnus knows better I think maybe
the pressure of the moment is getting to
him just to acknowledge James is
internet Gambit it happened again so we
will get him back as soon as we can but
right now we are running down the
stretch of this match Magnus Carlson
down by two points to alireza farooza
farooza has played an amazing match thus
far he deserves his lead will he be able
to keep it well he's got a great Center
Magnus chisels at it with Pawn to F6 and
we see that fuja takes an open file his
Bishop on E3 is loose he will not
blunder that I don't believe he brings
his next Rook on over but Magnus finally
finishes development so I think this
position it looks very unclear to my
eyes Bishops we like them in open space
against Knights but the knights are
actually causing some problems and
that's why we saw I'll just take the
knight in G6 it was attacking the bishop
on E5 Queen B3 a bad blunder apparently
there must be some tactics over on the
king side against this white king the
king didn't slap to G H2 to avoid any
pressure down the G file the bishop
slides back in touch with the King
Magnus he jettison's a pawn he is up a
couple seconds but that probably was not
the right decision and well otherwise it
says give me a pawn I'll use that pawn
here goes up the a file the bishop on D3
Hit The Rook it also stops that Pawn's
progress at least for now and with the
Rooks off the board that should make
others feel safer with his King his King
on H2 tucked away the black king also
saved by that outside pass Pawn that is
a nuisance that Magnus will have to
continue to keep his eye on he is up a
few seconds otherwise they're trying to
trade some pieces he plays B4 we might
see Knight C5 next trying to get those
Knights off the board and there they go
but this outside pass Pawn it's a
straggler it's by itself it doesn't have
a companion but that's checkmen one oh
my goodness Magnus Carlson hangs mate in
one and farouza takes a three-point lead
Magnus has enough time right there is
five minutes and 45 seconds remaining in
this match but you cannot give away
Checkmate like that not against farrugia
because ferrugia has proved to be a
difficult to point to defeat under any
circumstance but now when your back is
against the proverbial wall you don't
have time remaining and it's going to be
a tactical Affair a slope Fest against
fuja you can't afford that but actually
it seems like in this game Magnus he's
getting away with some of those choices
earlier D6 is loose D6 is a problem and
it seems like Knight F6 as well that's a
fork that wins material and I think you
can oh he there's a fork of his own
that's why he brought the king out to F2
and instead he now grabs The Rook grabs
the pawn up a pawn is Magnus Carlson
also has a 10 second lead on the clock
so he is doing very well in this game he
needs it he cannot afford to let this
Advantage slip he's transitioning into a
several Pawn up rook end game and here's
where Matt's strategy comes under play
what for should do is play this out it
doesn't matter if he's down three queens
you play this out until check and mate
except for user resigned and as soon as
he did we have Canty back James hey you
just missed a Checkmate in one and then
furuja unfortunate for him once he
ballooned that lead to three it's now
back to two because Magnus took that
last game
yep yeah this game right now we see a
position where
um white has stabilized the Knight on D4
uh we just saw a swap of pieces Black's
position A-Okay getting the king out to
H7 there's left for the king and it
looks like Magnus gonna open up the
queen side so you play on both planes it
seems like hey we do have James back for
real so James we just see Queen F4 it
looks like a mating attack coming down
to H2
absolutely no it was uh yeah I was
saying um that is the time is really low
in fact meaning like three minutes
someone something's gonna happen we're
either going to six game match
or somebody wins here and I mean Rouge
has not given up the leads yet it's not
giving up the lead so it's very
difficult to say who's going to win this
yeah this is looking good to win it but
Magnus needs to do a lot more if he's
going to try to make this boy a tie
breaker this is tough right now and a
few games ago it was Rook against rook
and each side had a pawn and Magnus was
up 15 to five seconds and he allowed to
draw do not allow a draw here you could
trade Queens that's fine in fact now it
looks even a winning end game because
g2's on a light square but just play
this out play quickly do not try to find
the perfect moves try to find good
enough moves and just do not allow your
last Pawn to go he will not do that he
can place his Bishop on D7 or on B5 and
now you flag your opponent
is holding he's already 15 says he has
six seconds here or why
but do not oh no no he allowed a draw by
repetition and that's the one thing he
couldn't do what he missed was King to
F7 the king could have escaped because
of the white king moved up to board D7
there was a move like C5 with check so
Magus allows Ali Reza to keep his
two-point lead and that is really bad
news for the world number one because he
can only afford to be down one point
when this match clock expires he has to
win now and you have to go for it he's
going to do it with the white pieces
here but we actually have a little bit
of a hold he takes takes
hey castles queen of three three six
three six seven up the pawn
and it's gonna be annoying though
because that Rook lands on E2 and I
guess there's no time but A5 A4 because
white will push his own Pawn up to A4
and stop that so he completes his
development by the way Rook F to B1 King
to F1 that Rook was almost trapped over
there and said The Rook is going after
those Queen side Pawns chat what do you
think is gonna happen Chad we got a
minute and 50 seconds Chad it is on you
what do you think is gonna happen is he
going to be able to do it him meaning
Magnus what do you think let's hear the
thoughts in the chat right now guys
right now we need to see it oh it's
gonna win oh man that's a
he blundered he blunt but he can afford
to draw because look at the overall
match like one minute 30 seconds remain
if he draws this then he has to win the
follow-up game and he's just letting
this one go but look at others clock
down under 20 seconds a 10 second lead
for Magnus Carlson and it looks like
objectively the game should be a draw
objectively definitely 100 15 seconds 15
seconds there for Russia time is moving
oh what a move he wants a passion of his
own
better Force the draw now otherwise
Magnus might win this game he's gonna
manage to flag him Magnus may be down
two pods win on time be Shameless
it doesn't matter how you get it it
matters if you get it done but here it
is this is the scariest part of Chess
right now this right here is scarier
than anything you've ever faced because
somebody is gonna blunder the roof
usually it happens and we see 3.5 for
alireza the thing about Magnus is he
needs to watch out because at some point
uh other reason might do the thing where
he puts the Rook under attack but look
at Magnus he's down to three seconds
himself he needs to move he needs to do
quick and that is a draw but Magnus he
he doesn't get the win but he's 25
seconds the last game will take place
and that means if Magnus wins we get
extra time for ruja only needs a draw
you see what's funny he goes for the G6
I don't know this is appearance but he
has to play more modern like
um in this way because he was looking at
hoping for King's Indian which is
understandable tells you a lot when you
need to win what do you go for King's
India oh okay that makes sense but at
this point this will turn into a pierce
or perk in fact with E4 and D4 he didn't
go C4 at all here very still likely to
be some type of King's Indian but it is
not the same it's not the same Magnus
needs to win chat will he do it check is
he gonna win is Magnus gonna win or not
the essential question because otherwise
this match concludes with alireza fuja
as the winner and this position looks
really good for black as he steals a
pawn in the center and Magnus ahead by
six seconds he's been faster at the
early stage of the game but in time
scrambles it's always for ruja who has
the upper hand
Magnus never got a chance to be up in
the mat I've never seen that before
actually but never got a chance
but right there that was a pretty bad
blunder from farrugia giving up the C3
pawn and here come blackspawn storming
up the board that Bishop on A8 that may
be the hero that Magnus needs oh but the
E5 pawns I thought he's gonna go E4 at
some point he drops his Central Pawn and
now Advantage back to ferrugia
time is up it is zeros This Is The
Moment of Truth here okay well Magnus oh
he's making a loose oh he's made it uh
he's even say nothing it's done Thomas
that's game that's match fine bro fire
with a clap there at the end you see the
gentlemanly clap and farouza he doesn't
even celebrate I mean he's still
probably feeling the adrenaline the
tension of that match but that is your
winner alibraza farouza yeah you get to
leave your chair now you've Advanced the
winners final you've secured minimum
twelve thousand dollars and you have
just beaten the number one rated player
on the planet the number one rated
player in history has gone down to Ali
Reza farouza the Iranian French
Superstar so James that was really a
tight match but I think farooja
certainly deserved it oh he definitely
deserted he was up the whole match when
can you ever say I was up the entire
match on Magnus he never got to leave I
won the game that's insane nobody really
says this ever only a few people on the
planet right maybe just two to be honest
but at the same time it's a very good
feat for farusha there in this portion
here Magnus did his thing he wasn't
paying there with the with the the
wrists and everything and the mouse
thing of Borussia got it done wow that
was epic doesn't care what your
opponent's up to you shouldn't care you
just need to focus on your moves on your
speed and farouja he moves on because he
just took down Magnus Carlson the number
one rated player in the world he has won
so many world champions but this is his
first foray into the bullet Chess
Championship we see at the winners final
alireza farooza's name has just been
etched there Magnus Carlson drops to the
losers quarterfinals directly where
he'll face the winner of Andrew Tang uh
and Jose Martinez but importantly we
have faruga in the winners final he will
await the winner of our upcoming match
our finale for the day Hikaru Nakamura
versus Daniel naroditsky that's going to
be an absolute barn burner
oh it's gonna be a big one I'm excited
for a chat we got Donya and he grew up
we certainly do but first we take a
break and when we return hopefully we're
joined by Ella razerusal but if not we
will go right into the action between
Hikaru and Dania
[Music]
thank you
foreign
everybody it's Danny here and as you may
know chess.com and chessable are now one
and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
in game we've added a new classification
called Miss for when a move fails to
take advantage of an opportunity but it
is otherwise a sound move we've also
changed the definition of blunder now a
move will only be considered a blunder
if it loses material or allows a
Checkmate coach will now draw arrows and
highlight squares when you hover over or
click on the highlighted words in the
move explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coaches explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are thrilled to be joined by alireza
faruja who just took down Magnus Carlson
in a long match aleriza how does it feel
um it feels great
I was kind of like I I saw myself as a
favorite from what Magnus played
yesterday and I was confident like the
way he played yesterday with Min was
very like not high quality so I said if
he doesn't level up I am probably the
favorite but yeah and I was lucky he
didn't level up soon but of course he
could always level up the level up was
real baby that was very nice Sally was
very nice to see there and of course
with that being said uh what kind of
training did you do for this uh that's
supposed to be a bullet Chess
Championship what did you do tactics or
like look at some certain lines or did
you just chill and relax
I I just checked heel openings half an
hour before the
um game and it happened in many of the
games so it was surprising and no other
than that I didn't even solve projects
I just came open my laughter when I
played that's good well whatever you're
doing is working other reason a question
I have for you is at some point it
looked like you left your computer and
it was after a tough game so I was
wondering because sometimes it happens
did you throw your mouse or something or
why did you leave
no because my second
tablet like second camera dropped and
that was the reason I got distracted I
lost the Rook so and I just went and
made their second camera okay but at
that point I was so
um tilted because I was up for in much
and I got distracted and I lost this
rook and then everything was
uh he had chance again
in the game of course so you got you
made it to the winners finals
congratulations who are you looking
forward to see in the in the final you
want a car or do you want done yet or do
you want someone
I think Hikaru will just win so it's not
what I want to see it's just who I will
see so oh why we'll see
well you know if you are to play against
a car or what do you see as your chance
you said you felt you were the favorite
against Magnus coming to the match I'm
guessing you're gonna say you're the
underdog against Hikaru but how do you
rate your chances against Hikaru
yeah against Hikaru um nowadays that we
play it's almost equal always
but um I I bet him in 2021
bullet championships so I have that
experience but okay he also beat me
before in 2019 final I think so um it's
always very close but of course he's
very sharp always and I expect a very
big fight song
so to prepare for the big fight how we
doing we're gonna go you know get some
food and then just open the laptop you
know 30 minutes before and maybe watch a
little Netflix is that what that's the
preparation for that match dude
yeah against Hikaru I could prepare a
bit more because I know these openings
of bullet I know what or because we
played thousands of games so why but uh
still we will see what happens but
I will try to check some opinions but
that's around about it
are you gonna watch his match against
Tanya as a former preparation you think
yeah for sure it's always fun
okay well we'll definitely say hi to you
and chat but we know it's again later by
you and we want to let you rest up after
that great match Victory so
congratulations that was seriously
awesome you have so many fans rooting
for you so we look forward to seeing you
in the winners final tomorrow
thank you
and that is alireza farouza he took down
Magnus Carlson you heard it from him you
know he's beaming with both confidence
and happiness I mean he felt like he was
the favorite based on magnus's match
against minlayan he said you know
hikaru's a beast he's won this event
three times but he took Hikaru down in
2021 so farouza he feels confident and
James I don't think it's a foregone
conclusion that Hikaru gets through
Dania this Daniel we saw yesterday that
was as you were saying leveled up oh
yeah that was leveled up Donna
definitely went crazy there you see how
good form Tang was to me he just went
crazy today against Eric Hanson but you
know Daniel went crazy against him which
is like whoa okay that Donya is
different it's a very different ganya
and we're gonna see that today but he's
gonna have to bring that same Donya
because Hikaru is always
most most expensive bullets very scary
to face minus one at three separate time
yeah and of course Hikaru an absolute
monster he takes on the Sensei the
Prophet Daniel neraditski up next but
before we dive into that match it's
gonna be delayed by a few minutes but
for a good reason we are bringing in
world number one Magnus Carlsen
Magnus is joining us for an interview
and even after the tough defeat so Magus
thanks so much uh for joining us how are
you feeling after that tough match
uh honestly kind of uh encouraged
um I thought
I thought I was just gonna be blown out
of the water after the first couple of
games and
um
I didn't feel like I had much going for
me at all uh I was incredibly slow and
scrambles I was Mouse slipping awesome
my right arm was falling asleep
feeling in my arm which I think was like
I was constantly like trying to shake it
loose in between games and so on because
I did yeah
um I mean obviously otherwise that is
is very good
um
and extremely extremely accurate but I
think the one thing that I did have
going for me is that I was always up
on time like I I wasn't able to make
good moves most of the time but at least
I was up on the clock which meant that I
always kind of had a um I had a chance
yeah it was uh making so it wasn't a
mouse thing here Magnus and uh we was
great to see you play as always was it
wasn't a mouse thing we saw that you
kept shaking we was like man is he in
pain like we wanted to it was like you
know helping you were okay he was like
man his hand is at the mouse is it this
or was it just a falling asleep or was
it the mouse
yeah I know the mouse is uh I mean the
setup here is not ideal but it's uh all
right but but it's it's okay yeah it was
more about the uh the arm just uh just
falling asleep and um yeah as I said
um
I mean I was very close to forcing
parsing overtime and uh overall the way
that it was that it continued I felt
that he was pretty vulnerable and it was
encouraging overall so I think like
if I get a few hours sleep or
for the next uh
next match
um
uh then I actually have a chance to
uh to do okay because I think like
This was
um just about the worst condition that I
could be in and still I I had a um I had
a chance like I think regardless I'm
probably
um still an underdog against
the the top two guys but um yeah I hope
to hope to be able to get another shot
yeah for a while there we thought this
might be your version of the flu game
Magnus because you're shaking off your
hand a bunch you know clear something
was bothering you but you know you said
you have some kind of new confidence
about your chances I when you were
jumping out to those leads on time out
of the gates was that part of your
overall bullet match strategy
I think that's the way that I I play in
general I know that I'm so unbelievably
slow in scrambles compared to these guys
that I I have to that I have to play
fast and uh I am to some extent able to
play good moves
faster than a lot of the other guys
um
so that's you know that's my my biggest
uh my biggest touch
yeah fair enough Magnus and last very
quick question for you before we let you
go and have some fun in Spain is in the
match between Dania and Hikaru Hikaru
the favorite what do you rate dania's
chances are to pull off the upset
uh I think it depends on on the start I
think if
um if your car gets off to a good start
is probably going to win fairly
comfortably
um but uh Hikaru can also be um he can
be definitely be shaken if he um
if he starts to to feel the heat so yeah
obviously I
it's pretty significant Underdog but um
yeah instead of organ conclusion
okay well Magnus thank you so much for
your time really appreciate you stopping
by and of course we'll see you tomorrow
so best of luck in the next matches
yeah thank you
and that was world number one Magnus
Carlsen here we have the three-time
bullet chess champion Hikaru Nakamura
he's won three of the four editions that
have happened thus far he is about to
take on none other than Daniel
naraditsky so James we heard magnus's
thoughts Dania he is a significant
Underdog but he believes that if he can
shake Hikaru in the early games he does
have a legitimate chance absolutely I
mean it's it's a chance for anyone I
mean even these we didn't nobody saw
David right uh coming out to where he is
so same thing it can happen it is a
match but this is a long match here so
it does matter about those games even
see him for ruja of four and then almost
botching it and not not completing it
against Magnus here we can see something
like that it is possible but Diana's
gonna have to get off to a very good
start against his magical
yeah you know you cannot afford to lose
the first couple of games we saw what
happened to Magnus when he dropped the
first three games against farugia it's
really tough to come back from that and
when you are the underdog when you are
playing against hikara Nakamura uh that
is really something that you have to
avoid so James I'm excited for this one
I think everybody is Hikaru being the
you know legend that he is the streaming
sensation also number two rated player
in the world in classical chess the
Fisher random world champion uh the
reigning champion of the speed Chess
Championship the defending Champion the
bullet Chess Championship I'm running
out of breath talking about his
accomplishments so I mean you know you
are up for the toughest of tough tests
half man half everything else is what we
like to say about ikaro the other half
we haven't figured out yet but we do
have Dania of course the prophet here
and very strong we all love them here we
go we got games
oh okay I know exactly where these files
are coming from I'm not even gonna lie
I'm not gonna say anything but I know
where Dania is getting this from right
now Daniel was the black pieces with a
little aliac and like oh my goodness oh
I mean I think it's more of a reckon
than an Al yankin because that 96 attack
hits the queen on d8 twice and so you
can try to save yourself here but it
feels like a couple accurate moves my
car you net oh Queen G7 is mate by the
way uh oh there it is jeez
uh okay you know what hey it happens
right get the Jitters out we see this
every game let's get the Jitters out
like it's one game you know what I mean
it's just one game let's not happen
let's let that get over that chat get
over that next game let's focus on this
game
yeah and look at Hikaru go he plays
Queen C he's Double Trouble Knight on f8
Queen hitting the E6 Pawn that one's
going down and the car does not mind a
queen trade because the E6 Pawn is
overextended and going to be lost and
queen takes G2 anybody oh that's just it
is oh my goodness
um
I just you know it's the Hikaru effect
moment of silence for a second you know
we've seen this already like you just
don't get overwhelmed right you don't
get overwhelmed chat we breathe through
it number one and number two is this
like two games right you know you need
to get the Jitters out just get the
Jitters out two games and then he's
gonna bounce back he's gonna bounce back
on you you know you're playing Hikaru
like okay everybody's gonna have you
right we'll get over to these two games
the two games here and then get back for
sure
I think as you said everyone struggles
with Hikaru you've heard every every
player we've interviewed say the same
thing uh faruja did have that confidence
I I really respected that from him where
he felt like he does have a legitimate
shot he has beaten a car before but
Hikaru he is stormed out of the start of
this match in perfect shape look at this
he wins a rook he's just not putting his
foot off the gas pedal
this is instant everything's instant
it's really computer like computer-esque
look at that in the bullet
dine is also faster right now and if you
look at the clock is the car gonna have
enough time to win this game I'm not
sure he does
we know who's better in there okay
whoa yeah so for everybody who's
confused two knights and a king vs alone
King is a theoretical draw you can win
by Checkmate if somebody kind of allows
you to do it you have to run to a corner
and get yourself checkmated but that is
a draw according to the rules and that
means that Dania survived despite
dropping a rook early on
they dropped a whole Rook guy somebody
was like well this is not looking good
and then he pulls off a draw here and I
did notice that rating difference is 50
points that level was crazy but also he
has been over 34 close to 35 I think he
has been 35 but
um having Daniel who's 3500 Daniel
Radisson 33.81 right it just happens
Dania has the finest footy he'll be good
we have seven wins no it doesn't yeah
you know you know how you were saying
how men lay he's a great defender Dania
has been showing some really sturdy
defense in this match thus far of course
that car's position is still better for
the moment but Donnie's not checkmated
he has a pair of Bishops he's still
fighting and that's all you could ask
for after you make an opening mistake
absolutely resourceful be very
resourceful and he's doing that he's
very good with the defense go with the
tactics as we know as well Knight G5
looks scary oh yeah it was blue mistakes
you know what's funny that tactic
probably won but they're moving so fast
that the eval bar does not have time to
react you know it stayed up there for a
while I'm like this doesn't look like
it's winning for white no that's that's
a thing of the past right now the
material is actually even white is
clearly better but maybe done it can
continue to Stave off some of this
pressure
before he has something there H5
where's the mate I don't see it Queen G6
and then Bishop G7
oh my gosh watch out for the white King
by the way
Donnie moving so fast but dinos down on
the clock th6 that might lead to a back
rank mate
thanks and it's winning but Dania has
done this before
but look at how fast the car was that is
the Difference Maker is against a
Checkmate on the board but when you're
playing when you're playing some of the
other you know top five players on the
planet they move slowly their pace is
not fast enough to keep up with Dania
but ikaru is all that and he is super
fast yeah I mean the speed there with
that Rook movement Shuffle shuffle oh
gotcha check here shuffle oh mate you
know that's how fast it goes here I'm a
fan of the c36 silver to kill myself is
what Dania is playing Daniel playing the
C3 Sicilian and it looks like we have a
pretty nice position wow
he dropping exchange yeah I think he was
kind of pre-moving over there and he
drops an exchange and Hikaru this is oh
it's the bishop on C5 is loose but you
get back ranked checkmated too quickly
that's the problem here for Donya and
well looks like another win in the
making for Hikaru Nakamura very
difficult it means Euphoria found a
little in between but I mean we're still
on an exchange yeah he's gonna trade
queens now forcing the trick Queen's
Right
mm-hmm
hey Karu he has jumped out to a
three-point lead against Daniel
narodeski and Don is playing some
questionable openings I have to say uh
you know I I see the influence of trying
to get a messy position and outplay
Hikaru and catch him off guard perhaps
but as we look at this position hikar is
currently up a pawn and he's protecting
his Pawn E5 no huge concerns at the
moment
one thing uh one thing that the car is
very good at is the obviously he's gonna
have a lot of things but one thing
definitely is the complications when
there are complications he seems to
thrive King's Indian player and stuff
like a very aggressive Sicilian player
back in the day so knowing this is uh
sometimes scary you get what you want
wait Rook G6 G6 is a move he moves out
of waking f8
uh whoa G6 I just want to note that
Hikaru is actually white in this game so
it looks good for the white pieces and
it is but that is actually Hikaru who is
delivering the damage to dania right now
between age six plays E6 look at every
piece yeah this is gonna hit the button
here we're gonna resign this is this is
crazy right now maybe he might try a
repeat one doesn't he tries it okay he
does try it because you can get a few
checks in just a few
and Hikaru you know he's too wise he's
not taking that Rook on B1 like he could
have with this queen he head Bobs he
gets another W and he is just out to a
four game lead so hiccard does what he
does best he just wins and wins and wins
yeah and at this level two wait a second
F4 have we have a lead here I think this
is for Dania looks good F5
is coming
from himself though
yeah car gets at five minutes still
strategically really good for white that
that much is clear but good defense by
Hikaru thus far
good formed by ikaro like why is he so
fast bro move it is accurate that's what
scares you is it's very fast and look at
the bishop H3 bro how you didn't even
think about bro what do you think can we
think for 10 seconds just tell we just
want to see no no James you cannot is
what hikara was saying and oh that was a
mistake though
oh that's why the Rook is under attack
you trade Rooks then Rook takes back the
bishop on H3 was loose
oh
he's coffee
I'm back I'm back I'm back and and the
featured chatter is talking about how he
car was ruthless I think that's a
mistimed feature because that was Donya
scooping up all the material and taking
his first victory of the match there we
go right that feels good now you strike
so now you feel better it really feels a
lot better when you win a game and
you're like all right cool I can do this
yeah I'm still down and we saw that with
Magnus he was down four games and almost
made it come back
very close
and look at a car or go he just gets
opposite colored Bishops he's going to
win this B5 Pawn so he's a pawn ahead
his Bishop on G2 is a monster on that
diagonal and it's completely unopposed
but Don doing the right thing trying to
open up lines for his Rooks absolutely
is he getting them I was getting some
play some activity
maybe King C2
B4 traps on as a pawn that's one and
move the Rook down
yeah he's got the three passers three
passers Robert one is already good two
is like very nice we have three passers
yeah and and they're like an escalator
there they're all just protecting each
other going up the board and that was a
win for hikara now Hikaru gets the black
pieces Dania playing his beloved opening
from the white side of this game and
well hey Cara I think has made himself
ready for this opening seems like he's
prepped definitely prepped here we
haven't seen a jar jar brings London yet
see what he does he can establish we
have four Bishop G3
stable four point advantage
and this game Hikaru he's made it
through the opening on Skate he has a
lead in The Clock he's a strong Center
and now he's going for an attack of his
own that's very annoying because I mean
look at the pieces all getting okay we
got some play man even bargain workout
F3 looks quite annoying at some point
and I would go for it but Hikaru doing
the right thing he knows how to time
these things but he takes and just says
why not push forward on the e-file
brought the f file oh my goodness Queen
E2 Bishop G4
that might be sick man check and push
but he has Queen D7 he plays it though
some like this is played whoa what is
going he makes it a knight he can under
the promote to a knight oh my goodness
oh my gosh he did it he did it
oh you see Donna just laughing there
he's having the time of his life he
under promoted to a knight to win that
game yes the delayed reaction you just
saw him react to the promotion so I
think he's streaming and so it's coming
in a bit of a delay but he also had to
laugh about that yeah that was nasty
under promotion to a night in a bullet
game too right oh man that was a nice
wow and now Daniel with the black pieces
we saw a king's Gambit although it
started from the Vienna but now we're
just in a king's gamut hikara played
this all the time when he was younger he
loves the dangerous lines but Dania
seems out of the upper hand yeah I mean
when in this game that's two games right
being down four I'm telling you look
these matches being as long as they are
you know you just get to settle in okay
I'm down four games whatever it is what
it is start playing and then you get
some positions you also when you go into
these lines sometimes you actually like
you fix things oh I played this in the
last game let's do this one let's try
this this time playing the same stuff
comes with sometimes better results
and Hikaru you know he is taking the
advantage away from Donya and also
making Donna spend a lot of time here so
it's upon lead for white and there's no
attack although that Knight's trying to
come to F4 and start an attack once
again that definitely is a scary night
it's gonna be a scary night yeah there
it is King H1 got out of the way Knight
she won and there is some pressure he
says get it all off the board
so trade everything even draw is likely
you know we're just gonna stop saying
that this is not gonna be a draw like
this is never a draw in his position
Dania playing this excellently he's
winning on the board but his clock is a
problem oh
man hung the whole thing
both players made it looks like and you
see a car react there is that the
landing stream and Donna has that little
smile like you know he's he's in a
trance and he's just happy to be there
he's happy to be there yeah and uh now
he got another game there he feels
better that's a little smirk you know
he's like I'm gonna play this this is
what I do and we see 30 second matches
especially if you watch him stream Donya
he does the 30 second matches all the
time with these guys and he's up on
already oh no guy is playing White
yeah hakara is upon habit opposite color
Bishops the good news is uh it's
probably should be a hold with best play
the bad news for Donya is he's down a
lot of time so Hikaru once again playing
at a blazing Fast Pace Hikaru is so
difficult to deal with in these moments
yeah because it's not only fast it's
like accurate and you're like yo how are
you so accurate this is why like that's
what this is where the half human and in
half what you know what are you you know
what I mean comes out when you see the
speed the speed is ridiculous here wait
but he's back he's back in the game and
that does hurt to move in some accuracy
obviously on both sides
uh
yeah that was classy by hakara there I
mean just the way he handled that whole
game and well hikaru's back to his
King's Indian excuse me Kings in King's
Gambit in a type of position and we see
that now has a Pawn on E3 what is
happening here this is crazy this is why
he likes this King's game and stuff
it's too complicated to figure out it's
scary bro like oh no oh my God 95 okay
yeah 95 is coming this is a very scary
position
so black is up a pawn it can Castle so
it looks like Dania has done well to
defend but a car has a lead in the clock
and the activity you say it all the time
and it's true king safety so important
in bullet chess absolutely King safety
and the activity is very important to
get active pieces and just weird tactics
just pop out of nowhere all the time
Rick F6 might have been the move there
oh hey Queen C5 yeah that's why King H1
no more Rook F6 Queen C2 Rick D7 his G7
Knight Rook F7 whoa he has King h8 he
slides out the way and says you can have
that pawn and what's the material count
it's even actually I thought that white
would go up a pawn but white was down
one to start with and now oh there must
be some tactics 95 watch out for your G2
Pawn that is definitely a thing he sits
up in his chair maybe Queen ooh he drops
a piece I don't think there was a move
what would he have to play they said it
was equal but I didn't see him move yeah
that could just be the Eva bar reacting
so 93 check is a fork so that's why
hikar brings The Rook back but now it is
a completely winning ending for Donya
and Dania is too fast to let this one
slip he's taking it that means that
Dunn's cutting this deficit back to two
back to two that's what it is a two-game
match but he's playing on here
Arrow knows gonna go down in this game
there it is get the Sip there it is
that's the win sip you know it's real
when they start sipping the coffee on
let me sit yep
and Donna said yesterday when we
interviewed him he has like seven drinks
he got water he got coffee he's got
juices he's got the whole Buffet of
drinks but right now he has the white
pieces and ikaru I don't know if he's
quite tilted but it's what Magnus said
you know he's not unshakable and
sometimes you lose a couple games and
you feel like you're out of sorts and as
soon as I said that Don is the one who
Blended upon the center he was who she
was being he's getting very fast which
is it's bullet chest like everything is
fast but he moved a little bit too fast
there which you've seen encourager too
as well and the speed here in every game
matters obviously so having end points
or 10 games sorry 11 11 games in oh what
happened Knight H5 takes what was that
oh he thought he was getting something
oh I mean I can understand it didn't
look good
like it looked good steak
those looks were deceiving and if Hikaru
takes this I'm pretty sure this is gonna
be like the fourth win for black in a
row so this has just been the oh Queen
you won this bishop F2 so at least
donya's he survived the game earlier do
you think he can survive this one as
well it looks too not after 35 yeah not
after a five F5 I was like okay you got
chances because it's strange but F5 was
a dagger
oh
it made the next move and
so fourth win in a row for the black
pieces three-game lead as you noted for
Hikaru hikar going back to these King's
Gambit structures and I think that's
good news for Dunder you get these
combative positions where he can try to
play quickly and out calculate Hikaru
absolutely yeah that's so funny even
mentioned in the sentence it seems like
a bad word like I'll calculate Hikaru
you said that like oh sorry all right
you know but he's gonna try to do that
too obviously
very few people in the world can do that
and Daniel just happens to be one of
them so he's going back and forth with
his Knight he doesn't need to make a
drawing he doesn't he goes rookie seven
he's actually the one ahead on the clock
for a change
that's good it could be and he's up he's
up on the board too and Eva bar like
this is your game bro take Stakes yep
looking good you have some attacks and
dark squares are weak on the king I mean
King being weak period there he is
taking advantage of the dark squares we
got a rook lift do you even drop the
point oh he dropping Brook in the corner
yeah so this eval bar clearly hasn't
even had time to react properly because
it was completely winning for black now
you see it there finally they pause for
a second and it goes back to uh just
about minus one so still good for Donya
on the board but the trajectory of the
games in the car is favor unless Donna
can find some kind of killer blow
yeah it's gonna be difficult we do need
to get the other rook and well they rook
in to this party here let's see rookie
two hold on bro Rook day two or
something he's in there he's in here
Dania with the
that game Hikaru not happy with the
result there it's a two point match once
again hey James you're right as long as
you can keep slugging he is in this
match that's it you just keep swinging
swinging and hope that you land well oh
he caught it oh open chin there uppercut
right oh got him this is exactly what's
happening it is a slugfest and both of
these players being very aggressive also
very tactical initiative very quick oh
this can go either way especially if
Dania finds his form seriously if I wish
he's starting I think he's starting to
really find some good form
although what just happened here Bishop
takes C4 Queen did he pre-move Queen D5
he knew that his car would take this
bishop his own Bishop on C4 was loose
and so he quickly went Queen to D5 what
in the world are we looking at Queen
takes D5 for black yeah he takes and
then he takes Sally takes because Queen
takes was on D5 I think
she's winning here he's trading blows
black winning a lot okay
six black wins in a row that's what just
happened that was the sixth win for the
player with the black pieces and that
means that it's once again a three-point
Advantage for Hikaru Nakamura
I like how uh Daniel nerdinski is
holding he's holding around them and he
looks like oh he switched names there
but he's holding around or holding there
it is it's all updated 25 minutes left
it's doable chat what do you think is
gonna happen chat what do you think can
Donya come back he has enough time what
do youth
are we gonna take
I mean the way his car has been playing
has been simply stellar and is this he
goes C4 did Hikaru he's just trying to
create some Pawn tension but if you take
on B5 the Knight would have been free so
both sides struggling to find their
exact footing in this game I just like
hikaru's speed oh oh H6 is hanging oh
mate my goodness
yeah look in there this is like what
that's what he just said like he said
how did you find that that's exactly
what he was like what
when Queen D2 happened you saw it
incident oh we gotta okay
and Hikaru just ended the winning streak
for the black pieces that was a win for
him with white and he now has a four
point lead
I don't want to call it this early but I
feel like now is the time where Don
isn't starting to be in must win
territory yeah
and I laughed because like yeah you have
to be a Muslim territory who's your
opponent Hikaru you just you what you
literally just laughed like I mean it
just doesn't get worse than that bro
like are you kidding me what do you mean
and let's win against who oh my goodness
but it's Bullet at the same time and
bullet things do change things do change
it is possible we've seen it come back
already
um but it is difficult he is on an
uphill battle here with 23 minutes to go
and Donna Frozen right now not making a
move he goes Queen B5 but quickly a car
responds with Rook to A8 and the Knight
of C3 couldn't move because the bishop
182 would have been dropping so he
finally moves his Bishop but now black
is up a pawn and has the much better
structure this should be another win for
Hikaru
this is insane it's very clinical it's
finding some stuff whoa whoa whoa whoa
sick that was so sick he went Knight G7
knowingly giving up the E7 Pawn because
he saw that he would attack The Rook 97
with his Knight and F5 then go to H4
with a fork that I can't believe how
quickly he spotted that yeah yeah I mean
it's really sick the tactics and really
is what bullet is oh I always say like
high level bullet is a lot of tactics
there's just a lot of tactics you get
tactics you never would see or get you
know in different time controls but it's
so many tactics here in this game geez
man this is getting bad now
this is getting tough incredible thing
that was
unreal and I think that as people are
saying that for
Hikaru like he rises to the occasion and
we saw him beat Magnus Carlsen in the
speed test championship last year he's
won many tournaments including recently
in Norway chess so for Hikaru he just
does what he continues to do his whole
career and he is taking down danielski
game after game right now yeah he is
it's uh I mean really not breaking in
much of a sweat which is crazy he's up
five games against Daniel who beat Tang
by like more than five games from my
death so it's a very impressive
obviously Hikaru is always doing this
but you know Dania has his chances man
it's tough you have to be so accurate
and you have to be quicker
Works trapped
unbelievable
unbelievable what Hikaru just sees
patterns everywhere and I think
sometimes we just like shrug it off oh
it's a car we're doing it no I'm not
going to do that right now it is so
impressive what he is doing because
Dania everyone watches his streams how
good he is we see his ratings I mean he
is that good and maybe if he had uh done
something a little bit differently this
match would be closer at the moment but
I just want to tip my cap to Hikaru
because the way he's playing this match
is just there's a reason he's the
three-time bullet chess champion that's
right three-time bullet Champion here
and like you know one of the greatest
ever do it here uh it's very very
impressive to watch him do this here
it's inspiring too as well for you at
home just work just work on your game
more tactics More Everything obviously
to get to this level but it is uh it's
nice to see we get to learn today here
this is a nice position for daniello
very nice we have something 97 oh man
oh my goodness
yeah you can see how upset Dani is you
know how much he wants this uh match
here and he still has a decent chance in
this game uh he can throw in Rook D7 but
that will allow the queen to sacrifice
up for two Rooks and
what now the white king looks way too
exposed yeah that is going oh yeah Queen
F3 is art
53 okay check up
King is gonna try to run Rook D7 okay I
think Oh What a fine by Hikaru I saw
Knight D4 but I didn't see the follow-up
I was like 94 was the follow-up check
tag takes eggs
[Music]
takes takes
qv6 it's a draw Jinx B7 he gets away and
Daniel With The Lean Back
breathe stop the bleeding lean back wow
we got ourselves a drawski
that was
a save if I've seen one from Dania and a
car is doing the right thing he didn't
take the pawn right away he waited until
he had .9 seconds and wasted the match
clock Hikaru he's been in these
situations before he knows how to work
it
is not only working the board he's
working the clock too as well I mean he
didn't have to hold that there's a lot
of time we've seen in the other matches
where like they just resigned okay cool
cool it's whatever or make the move
where in that situation make the draw
quickly get to the next game I'm up but
he actually waited that little bit of
time to get some seconds off the clock
to play Bishop H4 to make it a draw with
point nine on the clock wasting a little
bit of clock that's very very precise
and a car controlling the e-file right
now Dania has a bishop and a knight
compared to two knights for white and it
seems like there was a tactic on F6 like
Hikaru of course spotted it instantly he
now has a rook for I forget two pawns
excuse me for two minor pieces but the
safer King usually prevails and bullet
and White's King is tucked nicely on G1
yeah how's he gonna make progress here I
was just thinking that yeah Queen G4
looked good
he wants to Rook G3 okay
and if uh Queen takes H4 you trade
Queens of rookie seven at the end and
there's the rookie seven picking up the
B7 Pawn
face B7 yeah an outsider but outside
pawn and that is uh another game
yep
I mean hey Cara's just
too strong that's I think as simple as
that that Dania so talented himself I
mean he Andrew Tang by eight points
yesterday that was incredible but Hikaru
just next level at the moment right now
I mean finding everything being very
quick and also very accurate and just
posing a lot of problems
very hard to play that
just trying to figure out what's going
on in this game a bunch of trades on the
queen side uh but whose King is weaker
on the king side the King on H2 save for
the moment the King on h8 nothing's
attacking that so Hikaru looks like he
once again has a significant Advantage
yeah he's gonna take and play Queen G6
probably next with some attacking
chances on the G file which needs to be
defended he does
then it goes back a little tickle
and D5 is just loose Queen takes D5 can
happen next or not not right now after
C4 but the C2 Knight is loose and that's
why D5 could be captured oh he takes it
now yeah look at these extra pawns too
and what's not hanging he moves it back
and might go back around to G2
noticing GE two Pawn is now weaker due
to no Rook G1
tricky tricks tricks tricks everywhere
Knight is hanging both nights hanging
that is a oh Queen
find some moves boy I'm telling you oh
my goodness I love it bro I love it
this this was a clever game and hikar is
the one who played on right here he
feels that Don just King no way but
Donna says let me trade the Bishops my
king doesn't have to move I'm just
getting rid of your attackers one by one
there they fall Diamond's gonna take
this game
wow
that was sick that Queen C3 and he was
losing too
um
he was losing this one good job
and he stole the rook and Don is just
fat that pawn I saw it on H6 and then it
was gone but I didn't see how it was
captured you're right right it was so
fast and so pre-moved you didn't even
see it happen
Anya would have win he definitely needed
that he definitely needed that quick sip
you know
feeling better feeling good
yeah and I mean seven points against
Hikaru your car is 13 so he clearly has
the lead and is doing great but Daniel
he is making you know his fight clear he
is not
what is that what's the material count
isn't white down a piece
yes he is and B5
or yeah D5 closes them out check
first C3
oh he made it him it's me
oh
man oh it just happened he just had the
reaction
and you know what we have a five point
match I know that's a lot and it's a car
we're playing but when you get a couple
wins in a row like that maybe Dania he
is starting to believe
it's kind of funny because like uh
you know you're like oh it's now five
like that's like that's a good thing
like it's he's still down five games
it's really hard to to even you know get
anything from that being down five games
is tough but Donya one game at a time I
think he's starting to do that he ran
off two in a row here which says I can't
do three right stay in the mode take
advantage of this momentum and see what
happens and I mean Hikaru has played
this opening countless times uh these
kind of positions are very familiar to
him and now he's suddenly up a lot of
material so Dania is going to lose this
game I feel fully confident saying that
especially now the back rank check has
happened and Donya resigns so you know
it was five now it's back to six Hikaru
is not toying around
this is H4 early I like it
very ambitious play you're going for the
king side attack how could you not like
it
you're right G4 is coming next by the
way oh goodness oh he sucks oh my
goodness
he spotted it I feel for Dania right
it's just a
tough sledding against a player of
hikaru's caliber Queen before check C3
he's gonna try to trap the Knight I
guess but it feels like white has too
much extra material
I mean it's eight seconds off the clock
he did all of this in eight seconds wait
what is happening here Bishop G4 at the
end oh but Queen 64. that's the thing
that Daniel missed ugh
yeah contain C4 is nice those are very
nice using the pan oh yes weird I'm
about to say it's still some
complications oh yeah
oh he allowed that wait what is white up
a rook and a knight for like this is two
pawns but black might be better
somehow I don't see the spot yet um
hmm
he's winning he's like am I winning
that's what Diane says am I winning
that's the am I winning face yeah he is
Rook C2 check and I think that there's
nothing the car can do
Queen F1
F3 or D3 exactly
and that's right right there The Rook
bishop and queen they deliver the goods
and done he took that drink you know
he's happy you understand when you get
that drink what's in that cup Donya I
was just at his house actually what's in
that cup Diane and now no he's uh he's
definitely every time you see the the
Sip he's feeling good and that's the
deserved sip of coffee
yeah
and I think the Hat the happiest person
is not Hikaru it's not done yet for
trying to catch up it's Ali Reza I mean
he said he'd be watching he felt like
you know Hikaru is great but he feels
like they you know do go back and forth
in their matches and if Dania is taking
out a car in some of these games I feel
like that gives others even more comp
reason to be confident about his own
chances
absolutely yeah he's uh he's definitely
watching the match too as he said he is
going to watch the match here so see
what he's thinking about it what do you
think what's going to happen but hey
Dania is doing better he's doing better
from what happened here still down some
games got some time left okay maybe not
that much 12 minutes is getting close
getting close to the time
yeah it's 12 minutes remaining it's a
five point spread you got to start
winning if you're done and you got to
keep winning and oh that's not going to
help you win when you start dropping
pawns and pieces yeah yeah stuff you
start dropping the phones and these skis
blacks up he says yeah get out of here
you have to get out of there fast and
try to get more games in as quick as
possible
again I'm working I guess it loves his
own KD7 let's go we're having fun and
bullet hey fella let's go uh but this I
mean I just blocked it only looks good
now and I like that move though I can go
Bishop forecast for Queen side now is
really strong
the queen F6 to protect the F4 opponent
and white can't Castle either at least
not yet you have to play Bishop D2 but
then B2 is hanging so Dania has
prevented hikaru's King from getting out
of the center
I thought you could do Bishop E2 anyway
after it takes Rook D1 correct with the
idea of Bishop F6 and our Bishop C3 now
King E7 correct and then I don't
remember I was like I don't know what to
do now
as far in calculation but I was like I
don't know what to do now like this
should be I didn't even get that far I
was just like okay this looks
interesting probably Bishop B6 here just
to save your bishop and your B7 Pawn
both oh no Queen takes B7 seven yeah
yeah and now I can Castle first Maybe
not maybe have some trouble especially
before I love it
gave up a night just to keep your king
in the center like this
and this is pretty sick the defile
destruction and it looks like Dania he
resigns that game and with the lead now
all the way up to seven points well I
think that Hikaru knows that he should
be able to move on even if he loses the
next five games he still makes it
through so uh a car was just beasting
but as the chat is saying Diamond
getting nine points that's a huge number
and he might get a few more by the time
this match concludes
I mean it shows you how strong Daniel
really is I mean he just facing Hikaru
like it's like in a way of facing a
Magnus but you know or alireza is how he
heating up in his way to beat Magnus
even Magnus came back he was down four
almost made it a game match again or one
game something like that very close tied
it a few times so you know Dania really
really strong here but unfortunately uh
arrow is stronger
he is definitely showing that in this
game it looks like it's even by the
evaluation bar and the material is a
pawn up for black so it's one of those
times where I just don't believe the
evaluation bar I'm like yeah whatever
you say you know okay you say yeah
Stephen no it's not even no it's not
yeah this is practical I'm playing a
human you forgot that buddy huh
engine computer and then you like oh
well that was sweet wow engine says this
that's fire and sometimes like no no I
don't believe you right takes takes
takes takes everything straight up I'm
up a point okay this is even I agree
with that and now if you're done yet uh
draw is kind of the same as a loss so
you might as well play this out but a
car quickly playing Rook to B8 and I
don't know playing it out is a good
thing anymore for Donna he might just
lose this King opponent game
and let him just lose or let him just
get another point there I do have to
play it out but yeah am I zugged out
looks long
I'm okay yeah it should be fine it'll be
fine and I'm watching a draw for sure
there's on Hikaru once again wasting
five extra seconds he could have made
the immediate draw instead he's like I'm
look at the match clock under eight and
a half minutes let's keep that clock
ticking
thanks Queenie two
this was uh some type of like Grand
prix-ish
Syrian D3 Castle Queen side
what is happening in this game you just
gave opponent from Knight C5 okay
so even material but opposite sides
castling and I feel like there could be
an attack despite the fact that there
are no Queens on the board
A7 a7s and another thing Rook C1 First
Take 18 something he doesn't take Bishop
A7 hangs three four ons versus four
what are you taking here oh I'm taking
down this position for sure look at look
what he's doing here he can just win a
pawn at any moment the A4 Pawn is likely
to drop and
even on the clock so that's probably
good news for Dania as well because he's
got the bishop here and a possible
attack Rook B2
check yeah the bishop pair is very
strong we grab a pawn do have to watch
that pawn ourselves nice move C5 hey
oh we gotta watch the pawn bro we have
to watch the pawn he knows that and he
didn't watch the pawn well he's gonna
watch it promote and that's what
happened there in the end where you're
calling it the whole time you have to
stop that darn pawn and now it's over
because the bishop on B3 drops but until
that moment it felt like
there's some chances for done and maybe
there are Hikaru is trying oh nice C5
was really nice okay this finally should
do the trick Queen
I was thinking the same thing like where
is the mate he said nah forget it I'm
gonna give him any chances
okay so there's no Checkmate anymore and
if you're not careful as white C3 Fall
by Rook D1 uh is a possible mating
pattern
I'm gonna fight man I like it he just
does not give up here and fights it out
very quick
they say look at that he's fighting okay
this is a win
yeah yeah but yeah well done to to earn
that draw I mean that was amazing
defensive resourcefulness but I'm
looking at match clock as well in that
one game success Dania in the match well
that's good news for a car withdraw
continues uh to milk the clock and
Hikaru he's locked in his spot against
alibreza faruza in the winners final
tomorrow
this is from uh this is from a course
that I have dropping in fact you go E4
here Bishop C5 E5 Knight G8 and then you
go what is it 94. wait no
are they nice
they haven't moved now yeah I'm
wondering the same thing
oh it's waiting on the moves I was like
this is a long bullet game okay yeah
like oh I'm going in a 10 minute think
right now so I I think we are having
some technical issues uh I believe
that's the case so we will receive word
on what's Happening and get back to you
but for now no moves are appearing on
the board and
I think we're just as confused as
everybody else
I think they are playing though yeah
they definitely the zone you can see
they locked in looking at the board
analyzing yeah they definitely planned
five minutes left because the clock is
still ticking
yeah you can tell they was in the phone
I like the the board color change I feel
like we're in a new environment you know
like when you beat one boss in a game
and then you're into a whole different
zone so we got the green boy let's go at
the green boss let's go
um okay well we you know acknowledge
that hikar didn't win this game uh it
says uh one loss but we're we're working
on things everybody so stay patient with
us but it is Hikaru Nakamura has won
this match that much is clear that he
has taken control and he is well he's
better in this game because he's up a
pawn
okay look at that Rook down the E2
Bishop four takes takes
and yeah yeah
every trade every trade favor is white
right
easy
I'm good and no Dania has the black
pieces and he went Rook 8 just to see if
his car pre-moves something and that way
he'd win the rook and Donna does that
from time to time so now it is uh Donya
with the white pieces so um and we'll
we'll fix that in a sec everybody but
Donna he does that he like just make
sure that if he's completely losing that
you're paying enough attention and he'll
put his Rook on pre hoping that you
pre-move something else
yeah that's that's fine of course it's
the trick you gotta try it you know what
I mean you gotta try the tricks like hey
they work
they're working on all the time but they
definitely work oh Castle Queen side the
spice that's a big move now that
brilliant yeah yeah
Rick takes we can double up taking D4
next gonna take now
it was a great response by donating with
Knight A4 there he's just like all right
you're threatening Queen takes B2 I'm
gonna protect and attack and now we see
that Dunn is up in the exchange and her
car will he'll try to defend this it's
not going to be easy
rookie194 but he's doing a great job oh
my gosh how is Hikaru suddenly better he
trapped the piece
I know I know he really gotta relax
Queen B6 I'm still thinking about that
move he's answered with Queen B6 in that
position instantly too as well like
instant he didn't even think about it it
was so fast the spot there that's pretty
scary and you see done just giving away
all his pieces I mean he knew he had a
losing position and that was his
resignation before he pressed the button
so yeah Dania has been great that move
Castle Queen side was awesome Knight A4
as well but Hikaru he just is the man on
a mission and his mission is to win the
bullet Chess Championship and he's
making his way to the winners final
against alireza farrugia tomorrow
yeah and look at him having so much uh
like many points his last few matches
were all 20 plus
20 games plus which is really fast
really good really strong okay we got
the Sip you know look we know what the
SIP mean they could sit there yeah we
may not win the match but yeah I'm still
gonna sip this coffee or this water here
and we're gonna play this game where's
that Queen going buddy
and her car actually resigned so he just
knew that he was completely lost and uh
you know sign of respect he resigned and
in this game it's probably our last one
unless it's very short but Hikaru with
the black pieces he is playing King's
Indian defense both of these players
love that opening
now if absolutely Kings Indian special
place in our hearts right the kid King's
Indian defense if you like kyd let's
just put that in the chat we got two kid
players back to third as myself I'll be
my first GM over the board with kid I'm
not ever playing anything else things
any defense is life right
Chad if you agree
and I think
Daniel loves the white side of the kid
right now because he's upped how many
pawns four
all right he's up a lot of bonds yeah
knock it more in the chat there you go
Lionel correct yo fan Nakamura
Century in a way with the king's Indian
and he sacrificed the queen when the D3
that game was so sick
yeah bro I was hanging for like three
moves like we couldn't take
and can whites somehow get a queen is
the big question he's just pushing his
ape on he lost his beep on and then the
a pawn goes up and Dania is going to
take this game as well but it oh wait a
second if Donnie wins quickly we'll get
one more game
he said like if Daniel wins quickly bro
we get one more game but no yeah yeah
yeah
yeah so ikaru is the collapse for Dania
and that's real sign of respect he is
letting his clock run out because that
means the match runs out as well that's
perfectly acceptable and I think every
player would do the same so
congratulations to a car and Nakamura
for taking down Daniel nerdinsky and for
Dania I mean really a superbly played
match 20 to 12 is your final score and
Hikaru just continues to do those zakara
things
yeah he just dominated there I mean he's
used to doing that but of course Dania
tried to slow him down which he did a
little bit and then he ran off the games
and just got Full Speed Ahead we'll
steam ahead Hikaru here winning again
winning another match and going I know
order your face Ali resin
20 to 12. that was the winning margin
eight points for nakamura's closest
match of the competition and alireza
farooja awaits him Dania he drops down
to the loser's bracket there's no shame
in that you know who else is down there
Andrew Tang who else oh Magnus Carlson
how could I forget so uh yeah Hikaru was
a brick wall that Dania could not get
through a really well played match from
both participants and we're definitely
hoping to get an interview from them as
Hikaru Nakamura moves on we know our
Winner's final showdown it is akaru it
is other reason that will happen
tomorrow
wow is it yeah it's gonna happen it's
gonna be exciting guys of course farouza
called it too as well it's good to see
all the games today of course we do have
Magnus Carlson and the losers bracket
that's crazy there it's funny like if
you want to be in the winners bracket or
the loser like it doesn't matter where
you go you're gonna have a lot of big
heavy hitter waiting for you
no easy opponents in the bullet Chess
Championship Bortnick he moved on he
gets to play against paravian uh Ohanian
had to have a walk over there he was in
transit I believe so uh board Nick is
still in the competition that's great to
see and so many big names of the bullet
chess scene remain in the competition
some were eliminated but regardless we
have the biggest name of all coming up
for an interview that is Hikaru Nakamura
so you will not want to miss this stay
where you are we will be right back
have a friend or family member who loves
chess give them a chess.com membership
today and see them take their game to
the next level
you can choose a gold platinum or
Diamond membership for one month or one
year
want your gift to arrive on your
friend's birthday or on a holiday gifts
can be scheduled to arrive up to 90 days
in the future
all premium plans include an ad-free
experience unlimited puzzles and lessons
and unlock all Bots go platinum to add
unlimited game review or Diamond to
unlock insights and Coach explanations
give the gift of Chess today
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock app right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lines yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Nakamura Hikaru congratulations that was
an awesome match did you feel like
things went your way for the most part
or maybe do you feel like you left some
on the table
yeah I mean I I think uh I really could
not have asked for a better match I
think from the start Janet was very
shaky I mean probably sure lost like the
first four or five games just way down
on the clock and I think that really set
the tone
um you know once Dana came out shaky I
think he never really recovered I think
his confidence was a little bit off from
that point onwards um so I don't think I
was ever really in any danger perhaps or
like maybe two or three moments when it
was between I think it was up like two
or three games and he kept winning to
get it back to two points but
um overall it was very smooth maybe at
the end I could have worn an extra game
or two but by the but that by that point
it was already over so there wasn't
really a whole lot left to play for so
um yeah I just I could not have asked
for a better match I'm just very pleased
with my play overall
very nice Chicago congratulations how do
you stay in good form for these matches
I'm assuming streaming helps and sitting
there for like eight hours playing both
title Tuesdays but of course how do you
uh for the bullet portion you have to
move fast here are you playing a lot of
bullet or like how are you staying in
good foreign no I mean I don't play
bullet anymore either I mean it's it's
too much to try and play bullet for
hours and hours on that normally I can
put like one or two hours like with the
bullet brawl but that's about the extent
that I'm willing to play at this point
um I mean I think the main thing is just
having openings where you can play very
quickly and the moves are very simple
and it seemed to me that actually that
was probably the other thing that Daniel
completely got wrong is um it was very
clearly it spent some time looking at
something something like the Ali Atkins
with Warnick the I don't know it was
last night the day before and his
openings did not work out it seemed like
he was consistently down a good 10 to 15
seconds every single game almost out of
the opening and I think that was really
also a large part of the problems that
he had throughout the day so I I think
that you know
um in in general it's just a matter of
trying to just like find the openings
where there's some Rhythm and flow
that's I think that's the most important
thing this is where you can just make it
moves quickly on I was definitely able
to do that today
yeah you're gonna throw a really hot
start there and as you noted it got to
two points a couple times but then you
were able to win that middle section and
smooth sailing from there but you know
up next is one of the toughest opponents
you could possibly ask for in alireza
ferrugia how are you feeling about that
matchup
well I mean I played all I was in 2021
and I mean I think that match was
actually one hour and if that had been
like a 30 minute or 45 minute match I
would have actually won won that one so
um I do have some experience playing Ali
Reza of course I lost that match when
all of a sudden done in 2021.
um you know I think that it's gonna be a
very very interesting match I think if I
I think if I play the way I play today
probably I will win that match I played
like I did the other couple of days I
don't think I don't think it'll be
anywhere near good enough I mean I'll
probably get destroyed so uh really I
think the most important thing is just
to come out and not be cold I think if
you come out swinging from the start
like especially the I think this applies
specifically to myself and mag is like
we'll always be able to turn it on later
on in the match but certainly if we got
to a good start I think it's very
difficult playing on so my main focus
simply um to try and try and start off
well and if I start off well I think
good things will happen
very nice oh thank you for that is uh
what's your favorite bullet openings for
white and black
um I don't think I have a favorite
opening um but I definitely tripped up
Daniel today because like we've played a
lot in the bullet brawl and he continues
to play this D4 Knights three Bishop
four nonsense all the time and um I was
able to trip him up by playing with
Knight F6 C5 on move two and and he
never was able to adjust to it so
um you know I I think for for white I
would probably say just anything with E4
where you can play like E4 F4 Knight F3
stuff like that um with black I think
it's you know there there isn't a
specific opening that that works but but
certainly um you you have to play things
where you can get quick moves and also
like this is the other thing is the
annual in the black games when he's
playing the modern he was in a
situations where I could play E4 D4 like
the A4 Nation H5 Bishop C4 and I get
like six seven eight moves a Tempo very
very quickly
um and it just when your opponent's able
to play like that and you you can't you
don't have instant moves and you have to
use time it's just very very hard to
play so I actually the modern which is
an opening that I played a lot online is
it's one of those openings and it was
actually quite quite bad objectively
these days everybody knows what to do
against it so with black it's any
anything with white I think
um you know I think anything with E4 F4
Knights three nights or whatever it
might be uh generally is uh is pretty
good
yeah good insight into you know
repertoires and you know you're talking
about knowing your structures and being
familiar with stuff how do you get so
familiar with tactics that one game I
know your memory is phenomenal we went
Knight H5 to G7 to F5 to H4 it's like
you foresaw the whole thing coming like
how do you do that teach us
well I think it's just a matter of
playing playing Blitz and playing bullet
for for many many years I think I mean
that's that's how it goes I mean you
could say the same thing I mean Daniel
might have lost it but he he spotted um
there was one tactic they spotted uh
which one
there's some attacking spot in one of
the games that like I I didn't even spot
right off and and you know I think I
mean it's just a matter of uh playing
playing lots and lots of online chess I
mean I think at the end of the day if
you're at a lower level certainly
puzzles uh puzzles are the most
important thing for pattern recognition
I think the pattern recognition you just
get you just acquire it after years and
years so I think that's the most uh the
most important thing um at the end of
the day it's just pattern recognition
and all of us who are here have been
been doing it for many many years at
this point
we have a chat a feature chat question
from SJ and SJ McFarland says who do you
want to emerge from the losers break
um I don't know but I but I will say if
Magus has the same setup that he had
today I'm I'm very fearful for him and
his match against Andrew because I mean
that like I did obviously watch his
match I was covering it on my kickstream
and I think that um when Magnus played
Ollie Reza when they got into the
scramble like 10 seconds or less seems
like Ollie Rez was winning I don't know
like 90 of those I mean there's probably
two high because they didn't play that
many that many games
um but but I think that I'm I'm very
worried for magazine he has the same
startup and he's he's playing Andrew
because I think that's going to be a
very very scary matchup considering how
ridiculously good Andrew is when there's
no time on the clock so
um I think that's gonna be difficult for
Magnus I I would say I I think that if
Magus has a better setup um or maybe
he's not using a touchpad or whatever it
is he's using I think that he can
definitely um he can definitely emerge
but I think Matt is kind of a very tough
road getting there uh I'm really excited
to watch him play Andrew tomorrow and
then if he wins that play Daniel I think
I mean looking at the forms I think I
think Daniel's Informer or Andrew can
get into Times guys both of them could
beat Magnus so I think it's really close
to 50 50 unless Magus you know Jet's
home and in one of those private jets
like he did to La a few months ago but
back to Norway and I'm pleased with
himself said if he does that he'll he'll
come out and lose his bracket he doesn't
do that I think uh I think Daniel's
actually gonna emerge out of losers
bracket
wow a big praise for Donna he's playing
very well and that was a you know pretty
good match against you and a question
from Elias Edwardson says how will you
celebrate if you win this whole
competition
um well I mean I have the theater World
Cup coming up in in about like a week
and a half I think or something like
that so
um I mean there isn't there isn't much
to celebrate I think there's one thing
that I would say though you know there's
it's a it's great that there are such
events like this because you know when I
when I look back I've been playing
bullet chess for so so many years and I
remember even going back probably to
like the end of the 90s and into the
early 2000s there there I really wish
there had been Blitz or Not Sorry bullet
competitions for the top players of
times players like myself Roland
Schmaltz Hawkeye people like that
um I wish these competitions that
existed back then so I mean I I think at
the end of the day there's there aren't
gonna be any celebrations but I just
wish these events had existed for many
more years but nonetheless it's really
great to see chess.com putting on
putting on such events now um even if I
would have loved to have won for many
years it's still still great to see them
going on
completely with you and only one
Superman can come out of Smallville but
you know we're harking back to the ICC
days I Cara you've always been a star
thank you so much for joining us and we
can't wait to see you play against all
the races tomorrow
yeah looking forward to it see you guys
then
and here you heard from none other than
Hikaru Nakamura the defending bullet
chess champion he moves on to the
winners final he just beat Daniel
nerdinski by eight points and now he
faces off against alireza faruza who
took down Magnus Carlson so the bracket
is set we know that tomorrow we'll have
the losers round three we'll see
Bortnick and paravian was he tang in
Martinez and then awaiting the winner of
those matches Daniel nardiski and Magnus
Carlson so I'm seriously impressive
field it's being whittled down and after
immunohanin was dequeued oh it's under
Bortnick we didn't get to see him today
but we'll definitely see him play
tomorrow
yeah it's going to be fun to see of
course uh we have more matches guys the
final is now set here and you still got
people from the losers bracket they can
make it up right it always happens that
way so this is why it's such a great
format because you lose once all right
cool you make it to loses final and you
work your way back up you can actually
take the whole thing it is possible so
this format allows that which makes uh
all the chests be very very more
exciting and every match you win there's
more prize money to earn along the way
so it's always exciting in the bullet
Chess Championship no matter who wins or
loses and the same is true for POG
Champs and Pog Champs it is back POG
Champs 5 is coming your way soon as 16
of the world's biggest creators will go
head to head in the greatest event in
amateur chess brought to you by
chess.com and pogchamps Legend Ludwig
watch your favorite creators like cutie
Cinderella Sea Dog VA xqc tyler1 and I
did a thing and many more fight for
their share of a 100 000 prize fund and
a ticket to the live finals in Los
Angeles you heard me right but I'll say
it again live finals in Los Angeles use
the command POG and chat for all the
details so that event starts Late July
but tomorrow's a new day in the bullet
Chess Championship James it was an
awesome day today what do you think is
going to happen tomorrow
there's gonna be more of the same and in
fact more pressures on the line as the
games get smaller mean games meaning a
number of games matches that have to be
played so anything spots for only a few
up to the top way where there's only one
so will that be you is the question of
course maybe not Jack Chad's not playing
but we do want to see some great shots
tomorrow we will here's some great chess
tomorrow and then losers bracket in the
winners as well there's gonna be nothing
but the same
yes for sure we will welcome everybody
back same time same place this is the
bullet Chess Championship it's been a
stunning set of matches thus far and
there's some more to go before we find
out who the 2023 winner is you'll not
want to miss the action come back
tomorrow please have a good one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you